hey what's going on it's bill burr and
uh it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and this is my fifth attempt
i'm gonna set 15th to exaggerate but
it's really my fifth attempt
to do this [ __ ] podcast and i could
effortlessly effortlessly just talk
about what the [ __ ] just happened to me
but i'm in a different place in my
[ __ ] life right now
so i can't do it
i'm gonna [ __ ] tell you the story one
of these days
oh my god i just have to wait till
enough [ __ ] time goes by
and i will tell the story and i will
tell it and no one's gonna [ __ ] know
it's one of the disadvantages
of one of the few disadvantages of doing
what i do for a [ __ ] living is you
can't [ __ ] experience something that
sucked and then that night go on your
podcast and say that it sucked in a
vague way because people will know what
the [ __ ] someone will figure out
you know all right [ __ ] thumb second
working
they figure out what the [ __ ] you're
talking i don't want to bring any
[ __ ] grief to somebody but jesus
christ
jesus [ __ ] christ i know it could not
be any more vague
anyway
anyway i i don't like like this is gonna
hang over my [ __ ] head
for this whole [ __ ] episode but
anyway the nba finals finals start
tomorrow it's the stanley cup final but
if you say it's the stanley cup finals
there's always some douche from canada
that's got to be like it's the stanley
cup final um there's only one of them
well explain that to the [ __ ] nba
somebody please explain to me the nba
and i'm now gonna sit there i'm gonna
watch
the nba
finals plural i believe i'm gonna watch
it on mute
because
i um
i'm just under a lot of stress right now
trying to get my [ __ ]
this thing [ __ ] edited and the last
thing i need is to watch
these stupid ass [ __ ] referees
dictating the goddamn pace
you know and doing everything they can
to make sure it goes seven
and all of that [ __ ] everything that
anybody with half a [ __ ] brain knows
that they're doing
you know what i mean just keep it
competitive keep the game close and then
we'll let it we'll let them play at the
[ __ ] end and then you know
who gives a [ __ ] who wins if it's
[ __ ] close that's great who cares if
we [ __ ] somebody out i know
i just uh you know but it's you know
it's a boston team so i have to i have
to sit there and watch it my left foot
is literally twitching right now
you know
um this is how much i hate the [ __ ]
nba
that
as much as i was excited that the
celtics were going to the finals my next
thought was [ __ ] now i have to watch it
okay and i gotta watch these [ __ ]
idiots every time somebody takes a
three-pointer sticking their [ __ ]
three fingers up in the air why are they
doing that
you know why they're doing that
for the worst [ __ ] reason
an adult could ever do something because
everybody else is doing it what are you
[ __ ] five years old you stupid
[ __ ] [ __ ]
put your [ __ ] hand down
you know when a [ __ ] adult's gonna
boo all of the horseshit that goes on
the second is a stoppage of play like i
don't [ __ ] get it like
you're watching some of the greatest
athletes
on the [ __ ] planet isn't that enough
you know it's got to turn into the
barnum bailey [ __ ] circus a bunch of
tumblers going out there and like
i don't need a [ __ ] dj
to [ __ ] teach me how to [ __ ] cheer
or turn it into like a dance party
i'm at a basketball game you don't need
to [ __ ] multitask here
everybody clap your hand get get get gay
every five [ __ ] seconds
how about i clap my hands when i'm
watching the [ __ ] game what am i
clapping my hands about
ah this has nothing to do with that
it has to do what the the [ __ ] happened
to me tonight and i i gotta get it oh i
gotta get off my chest
i don't i don't want to you know
it's my wife's birthday week
so i'm gonna be like
in a good mood but i was i was sitting
there
you know when you've just had it
and the person you're with knows you've
had it
right but you don't say you had it
people ask you if you're all right
you're like i'm fine i'm fine right and
you're just sitting there
and you're not looking at anybody and
your eyebrows are up
you know you're just [ __ ] staring
at nothing
really
and you're just counting down the
seconds how much longer you're gonna
have to be in this [ __ ] place that
you don't want to be in and people are
coming up to you is everything all right
yeah i'm fine
okay
because you don't look fine
well why don't you take the hint then
why don't you take the [ __ ] hint
obviously i'm not [ __ ] fine
then why are you saying you're fine
because i'm being a gentleman
all right and you don't give a [ __ ] that
i'm not fine you're just [ __ ] curious
cause your life is so [ __ ] boring so
you have something to talk about
oh jesus bill
oh jesus mary and [ __ ] joseph um
you know i went somewhere the other
[ __ ] day
and i couldn't finish my food
and i asked if they could put it in like
a box or whatever and the woman came
back and she just handed me the box and
i'm looking at her
she goes sorry i can't put that in there
because of covid
it's like what are you gonna wipe your
nose with it it's your [ __ ] hands
i mean i got one of the most brilliant
[ __ ] excuses now is it's because of
covet
check into a hotel yeah hey there's no
blankets on on on the uh on the bed yeah
yeah we can't the linen with with covid
what am i supposed to do
uh did you bring a jacket
uh is the room still gonna be the same
amount of money well you know actually
it's extra because we have to you know
allegedly fumigate
you know
we buy a can of lysol for [ __ ] thirty
dollars i would have their price gouging
and then we just
and then we charge you 85
on your bill that's
yeah that's what we do
um
all right let's let's talk about
something positive um
i met a blonde
uh female that i've become really good
friends with
she's beautiful has big brown eyes
and four legs
i you know once a day
me and my my co-writer
you know you're editing a movie and at
some point you just have to take a walk
so we go for this walk
and we went down this this little
alleyway
and there's
there's horses down there and there's
this blonde horse
whatever you call it looking like
trigger right
and i've i've become friends with it
like i walk by now and it like stomps
its foot or whatever and comes walking
up to the thing i rub it on its head
and the muzzle and all that and it's
like makes my day
[ __ ] love horses
i swear to god someday you know
it's a classic old man hey someday i'm
gonna have a horse
i would love to have a horse and never
ride it
you know one of these horses that's been
ridden its whole life
and when i buy it right
i just walk up to it i take the saddle
off and i walk to the front of it and
i'm like hey horsey you see this and i
just [ __ ] fling it it's over all
right you're with me now
you just [ __ ] run around and have a
good time come back to the bar and i'll
feed you
wash y'all keep you nice and but this
whole [ __ ] is somebody riding on
your back that's over you put your time
in
you put your time in
i like horses
i don't understand their purpose though
you know with their teeth that they're
obviously prey
like wild horses
couldn't drag me away
like first i actually you know for as
much as it sucks
that they're broken you know what i mean
they break them
ain't nothing better than feeling that
horse quit
um
the alternative
walking around the wilderness
and i would imagine
they're run down by packs of wolves or
like a [ __ ] grizzly bear
some [ __ ] back in the day
it's kind of a strange animal i guess
they're all [ __ ] weird
think of that whole family like dear you
understand cause they're kind of like
decent to look at
like moose
you know elk is like sort of the jock
older brother
of uh deer or venison you know what i
mean
like even a a a beautiful buck you know
it's still like a pretty boy
you know one of those you know he goes
to the gym but he's never really had a
fight you know but elk
you know elk's got something else got
some issues
that [ __ ] moth just flying around
flying around my [ __ ] room
what a weird existence
you guys believe in reincarnation you
ever think you come back let's let's get
back to that then you got
the moose right
just basically i mean
i don't know what those things i don't
even understand what those things are
what i don't understand is how a bear
can kill a moose or why a moose doesn't
put up a better fight
the big problem you know the big biggest
problem with prey is is they run
you know there's always way more of them
i love when you know what the ones that
i really like is those those one of
those cape buffalo or whatever in africa
every once in a while they get really
[ __ ] pissed off and they take the
fight to the lines the lions turn around
run away it's like that that's what
they're your guts what you do
that's what you do now you got a victory
what do they do the next day
they start running away i don't
understand why the [ __ ] they're the size
of those things
and anytime they take a step towards
those lions the lions [ __ ] run away
by the way when did the lion sort of
become
like the animal when when you know when
you're one of those bullshits [ __ ]
[ __ ] self-help people on instagram
and they're sitting there going like you
know some people you know
came to play the game i came to [ __ ] it
in the ass and
whatever they say something like
this this that that vague [ __ ] talk
you know what i mean like you don't even
know what the what business are you in
how are you applying this and they
always say it there's always some
[ __ ] lion like walking around
there's another comedian she we always
joke about that [ __ ] we're always
sending those things to each other and
uh
some point whenever this [ __ ]
[ __ ] stops
who you get together we're gonna just do
a whole [ __ ] episode dedicated
to this fake [ __ ]
[ __ ] self-help
just people making up [ __ ] you actually
when you really watch it you you get to
see
the uh
i don't know
just the responses it gets it's just
like wow there's just a lot
of [ __ ] uh
unhappy people out there which i know is
funny
to hear from me after the way i've been
behaving on this podcast but believe it
or not
like i'm not like
uh
you know i like my life
there's just certain things that when
when
the [ __ ] that happened to me tonight
it's just [ __ ]
i i don't even know um
i don't know
just beyond disrespectful
like you're charging money for this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
um
anyway
i don't know
i'll [ __ ] get over that [ __ ] at some
point anyway uh so the nba
start tomorrow here's my prediction
if you want to hear from a guy who never
even played [ __ ] organized basketball
in his life at any level
um is gonna seem obvious but my my thing
is i feel like game one is the most
important game of this series for the
celtics not for the warriors
for the celtics it is
i feel like we have to go out i'm
assuming we're playing in that building
we have to win game one
and we have to prove to ourselves
and to a lot of people that we can beat
this [ __ ] team
which i know we can't but i i really
feel like
the warriors because of their talent
level and how many times they've been
there in recent times and the fact that
there's so many champions on that team
and they know how to win
that you could easily get steamrolled by
this [ __ ] team
so i think it's really important that we
go out we win game one
you know guys on our team feel good and
you get the warriors thinking like oh
[ __ ] these guys are better than we
thought that's that's a good place to
have your opponent thinking oh [ __ ]
that's what the [ __ ] you want as opposed
to uh
you know doing the ric flair [ __ ]
the [ __ ] the ric flair strut down the
down the goddamn court after hit you 90
or three point i mean
steph curry's is
i don't know i don't know much about
hoop but as far as i can remember he
might be the greatest
outside shooter i've ever [ __ ] seen
you know honorable mention andrew tony
obviously larry bird
uh
and i would say
kobe bryant as far as i don't think i
ever saw anybody
be on the three-point line with two
people [ __ ] hanging all over them
and the thing just went in like
that's [ __ ] amazing
so uh definitely have our work cut out
for us and um
i'm excited about how young the celtics
are and that they are in the finals i
just hate
the officiating
in the nba it's like can you just [ __ ]
off
and let the game happen
you know i don't know it's a really
weird sport man it's a really
really [ __ ] weird sport so anyway and
they've had corruption problems i think
for a long [ __ ] time and they blamed
it on one guy there there we go with
that enjoy the finals
sorry
um
anyway i've been following this guy on
instagram let's just change the subject
to something more positive all right and
if you actually like elk and moose i
i'm sorry for my comments earlier
you know
maybe deer aren't that beautiful
maybe that's you know
society told me that they were beautiful
and i don't think for myself so then
that's why i say that they're more
beautiful than a [ __ ]
moose i guess i don't [ __ ] know
[ __ ] animals i swear to god you look
at a moose and it's just like what a
waste of size
i can't see some guy you know
i hate when i see a guy that's like
6'4 and they can't jump
you're like what the hell what a [ __ ]
waste
you should be out there dunking on
people
look at you
painting
um
decided to become a 6-4 artist no one
wants to see that
i look at like moose
mooses like that right
i hate you mises to pieces i look at
most moose in that way right i'm doing
the brian regan bit here
what a [ __ ] waste of size
they got these goddamn things they
should be out there
in tandems
like the buddies system and scuba diving
and they should be hunting
[ __ ]
bear
you know
why don't we make this our territory
instead of just walking around
like these anti-social [ __ ] like they
don't really walk around together do
they
i don't know i really have to be honest
with you man like i just feel like the
whole way
this [ __ ] is set up
you know
the amount of murder that just goes on
every day from human beings all the way
down to insects everything's out here
just [ __ ] this is a really wild
[ __ ] place to live
earth
hey can i talk to anybody like if you're
in a bunker right now and you're one of
those doomsday people or whatever you're
waiting for the dollar to collapse and
you have your whole [ __ ] thing set up
and everybody makes fun of it you know
but who's kidding who you know you're
going to last at least an extra 48 hours
than i am
depending on how many people you told
about it
here's my question
do i have a question did i completely
forget i started looking at that [ __ ]
moth
what if i open the door will you just go
out i don't feel like [ __ ] killing
you too i was talking about all the
[ __ ] murder that goes on
um
yeah i just i just don't think that the
whole thing you know what i did that
[ __ ] [ __ ] tonight just really
just [ __ ] threw me all off my game i
was going to be in such a good mood i
was in such a good mood i i you know i
walk down the street every day i get to
take a stroll during the middle of the
day how [ __ ] lucky am i right not
only do i get to do that and there's a
[ __ ] horse on the way
and the thing's cool is [ __ ]
and i've been doing it for like two
three days now it's exciting when it
sees me it does a little [ __ ] stomp
on the ground like oh [ __ ] freckles is
here
makes my dick
it kills me i can't feed it the sign
says don't feed it so i'm like all right
you know
not gonna feed the [ __ ] thing but um
anyway um
i don't know what else to talk about i'm
missing all the hockey playoffs i heard
the avalanche edmonton series is
absolutely insane
uh
i cannot wait to see um
the who the who saw the [ __ ] rangers
going to the eastern conference finals
the rangers winning at game seven i
think the one back to back game seven's
two series right
um
who knows they got a hot goaltender
got a couple other people i don't know
anybody anymore i don't know what to
tell you guys
um i'm supposed to have some advertising
i don't know when that's coming in but
uh i will read it when i'm supposed to
and uh through the magic of editing
you won't realize that uh i've taken a
little time off here but however
um
oh god
i cannot [ __ ] wait i at some point
i'm gonna tell that [ __ ] story what
happened tonight and it's just like
oh my god
the
[ __ ] kinds of people i was around
tonight
i swear to [ __ ] god man useless
useless
like disposable [ __ ] people
just [ __ ] useless
and uh there's just something about them
they win
i don't [ __ ]
get it sometime this is a dangerous
thing to say i probably i i'm i just
sometimes you feel have you just see
people it's like
those people that are doing well because
they don't give a [ __ ] i don't mean like
they're being themselves
i mean they literally don't give a [ __ ]
about that fellow [ __ ] man
you know what i mean which just you know
there's no [ __ ] guilt you just just
keep plowing ahead and you don't give a
[ __ ] about the wreckage behind you
um all right and with that
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday june 2nd
2014.
oh my god is it really june yes
yes
uh uh trisha
[ __ ] june comes after may every
goddamn year
that's right the summer time is coming
you know
you you should have started going on
your [ __ ] bikini diet back in
february but you didn't
you got all wrapped up in your life
didn't you well it's not your fault
trisha why'd i pick tricia i don't know
why you know what cause i'm sick of
saying karen and kathy
i'm gonna [ __ ] make fun of some other
goddamn names and i'll have the audacity
to do it even with a name like bill a
nice generic [ __ ] name no imagination
you know
actually it's a i actually like my name
i don't know what happened somewhere
along the lines
about in the 90s you know what i mean
everybody started to have all these
[ __ ]
those names george carlin made fun of
right george collin
you know dakota
and all those things all those names
that had to sound like a [ __ ] canyon
right
now all those people are coming of age
and all of a sudden i saw my first i
don't know i was watching some sport and
they [ __ ] over to uh [ __ ] dakota
something and i'm like am i that [ __ ]
old that somebody named dakota is old
enough to play a professional sport
um sorry anyways i'm in a weird mood
today i uh this the podcast is actually
late this week i'll give it to you
because it's not even monday morning
you're probably thinking why bill you're
a [ __ ] comedian you're a bum you
don't even have a real job how come you
can't get your ass out of bed early
enough
to even record it on your monday morning
well i'll tell you why last night
i uh took the lovely nia out to the
hollywood bowl and we saw bruno [ __ ]
mars
with uh
pharrell
or farrell
i don't know how to [ __ ] say his day
pharrell the guy who by watching his set
evidently wrote 40
of all hits in the last 15 years i was
just standing there as he went in from
song to song
going like jesus christ this guy uh he
wrote this song too
it's just him i thought that other guy
sang it and then my wife would be like
no
he produced it for him and it went all
these grammys he's kind of awesome
i know he kind of was he was out there
with his his big smokey the bear hat
this one was red probably a special one
because he's playing the hollywood bowl
that was a great thing about the show
last night you could tell that both him
and bruno mars were really excited
to be playing the uh the hollywood bowl
it was great they were just phenomenal
[ __ ] performers and uh
you know
the only thing the whole night
i would say was pharrell's uh
backup dancers
they were dressed like they were still
at rehearsal that's the only thing i
didn't like
you know
i'm sure
obviously they did it on purpose but you
ever watch one of those movies like fame
or uh
i don't know
bill and ted's big adventure one of
those [ __ ] movies from back in the
eights the dead eighties the [ __ ] did i
say aids the eighties the aids eighties
on vh1 who got it who didn't and who was
surprised uh about the results
um the 80s
um
what the [ __ ] you know there was a bunch
of those those movies michael douglas
don't dance all of those movies
when they would be in rehearsal right
and there'd be all these [ __ ] smoking
hot women
dressed like they were gonna paint their
bedroom
that's how uh pharrell's uh backup
dancers were dressed last night and
other than that i thought it was great
he's saying all these [ __ ] songs
i don't know he's saying that one with
the guys who dress up like the robots
you know
yeah i'm up all night to get lucky i'm
up all night to get something i'm up all
night doing blow
yeah
right and everybody's going nuts and
there's a disco ball it's a great
[ __ ] time
great [ __ ] time and i'll take you
through the whole goddamn concert so
we're sitting there right now i'm one of
those people i never
see uh like nia can spot famous people
all the [ __ ] time i never do
so we're sitting there we got we got
great seats
and uh
she hits me on the arm she goes oh my
god there's henry winkler and i look
over and there he is the fonz
henry winkler having a great time
dancing to pharrell
and then in between the break she
[ __ ] elbows me again it's like oh
there's tom hanks swear to god there he
is
standing in the aisles
people are coming up to him and he's
grabbing their phones and doing a selfie
forum
he looked like he was running for office
he stood there for like a half a [ __ ]
hour
like
you know my wife was going look at that
he's like the greatest look he's like
he's the greatest guy ever it's like
yeah i guess that's how you have a
30-year career you have a 30-year career
by doing exactly the opposite of what i
do
i can tell you this after watching that
man stand there for a half an hour as
gracious
as as you could possibly be with anyone
and everyone who walked up to him um i
can honestly tell you without a doubt
that tom hanks does not have one drop
of [ __ ] in him he's just a [ __ ] great
guy i already liked him and then i
watched that i'm like jesus christ
you know i need to work on myself this
guy is putting on a goddamn good [ __ ]
clinic
here at the hollywood bowl
so uh so now i'm like jesus christ
there's all these [ __ ] people here
nia's like oh there's natalie cole
there's this [ __ ] uh eddie rabinowitz
i i didn't even know half the [ __ ]
people she's pointing out so i start
looking around and i go look at that guy
over there with the jackson brown hair
cut he turned around with jackson brow
he was not standing in the aisles
but does that make him a bad person
maybe that's the cuntiness of tom hanks
because he does that now you're
expecting every other famous person to
do and then when they when they don't do
it
bet all those famous people are just
sitting there looking at tom hanks
staring daggers at him like why won't he
just sit the [ __ ] down
he doesn't like doing that either
they're all [ __ ] pissed
i mean he's been out there for half a
[ __ ] hour
you know and then all of a sudden they
all seem approachable
i like the handlers there was a couple
of handlers when they were down there to
basically be a security person
what you have to do is you have to
master the hand an inch away from the
small of somebody's back
you just sort of leave it there
you know i don't know when if they got
like any uh [ __ ] inner ear piece that
then says when they actually make
contact with the lower back of the
famous person to guide them through but
the thing is
when you're you're in the ready position
as a security person you have your hand
in the small like an inch away
right like you're warming your hand on a
[ __ ] fire except it's some famous
person's lower back this guy stood there
the whole [ __ ] time and every once in
a while he just sort of shift the person
it's incredible i don't know how his
[ __ ] arm didn't get tired just
holding it like that you know i bet he
has to do stretches
so anyways
so pharrell comes out it's like broad
daylight he's got to perform that i
thought he did you know
i don't know just as a comedian
performing outside in broad daylight to
me that just says oh my god i'm gonna
bomb and uh
um i better get the check before i go
out on stage that's what i see but he
was
he was phenomenal
um
and then then bruno mars came out
and it was uh
i don't know dude i called it nia told
me that she's like you called it you saw
this kid like whatever three four
[ __ ] years ago you saw him on
something
and you were i did i was like this guy
he's old school this is a song and dance
man here this is throwback this dude can
do anything he's gonna have a long
career the only thing stopping him is
him
and he didn't stop himself and there he
was and he put on a [ __ ] unbelievable
show his band was awesome his drummer
was [ __ ] sick
he introduced him as his brother i don't
know
i don't know if he meant that in a cool
way
or we literally came from the same
parents i have no idea
uh but that guy was killer and then his
band was [ __ ] amazing and uh what i
liked about it was that they were like
they were silly they were having a good
time and they were killing it
and there were moments during the show
where they were [ __ ] around trying to
make each other laugh and [ __ ] and uh
i don't know man it was just it was an
amazing show and i also
you know with each concert i'm getting
older and older and i really should have
you know like when you see a uh
a performer on stage
you know and they're just [ __ ] old
now and everybody says like oh man he
should just stop she should just quit
hang it up you know put a couple of
shirts on if you're gonna go out there
jesus christ at least hit a [ __ ]
treadmill or whatever they say
you know we should just stop you know i
think that that goes with audience
members too
because i got to tell you last night i
can't even tell you how many times i had
to sit down because just literally
standing up for too long my lower back
starts killing me
and i remember sitting down at one point
as bruno mars is on the stage and he's
[ __ ] sitting there going uh
you know hey the [ __ ] left side ah
the right side now down the center and
i'm just saying if this guy sees me
sitting down
you know
i don't want somebody on stage seeing me
sitting down thinking i'm sitting down
you know because i'm not appreciating
what they're doing i almost wish i had
like a neon sign that said it's not your
fault
it's me i'm [ __ ] old
and i was literally sitting there
laughing as i'm drinking a water
you know like i i was actually
exercising rather than just trying to
stand up for longer than 12 minutes
and i sat down and i really thought
about it i was like is it am i too old
to go to a concert i i i think i need to
retire
you know because i'm getting to those
scary years when you're older and you go
to a concert and you just feel the need
to put on a i'm going to a rock show
t-shirt
you know what those older white guys do
and they'll put on one of those [ __ ]
justin timberlake hats
and you're wearing a t-shirt which you
know unless you kept yourself in shape
you should never be out of the house
with a [ __ ] t-shirt on
you know with your [ __ ] man boobs
you know looking like b-cups
just sitting there and then you have
some sort of bedazzlement on your
t-shirt to let people know that you
still can rock
you know
and you show up with those [ __ ] jeans
that just say
i saw [ __ ] molly hatchet back in 82
or whatever the [ __ ] guy's name is
right
like you i just don't want to be that
guy
and um
i'm not gonna lie i saw a lot of that
last night which is just a testament to
both of those guys how talented they are
because it really was everything from
little kids
um little kids to me like 14 15 all the
way up
to like i don't know how old's henry
winkler like 70.
um
but anyways and it was funny there was a
guy sitting in front of us
this old dude
who was well into his 60s i think and he
was part of that last of that generation
you know those older guys from that
generation
that just always walk around with that
navy captain's hat on
you know some of them was because they
were in the navy the rest of them i
don't know why they wear it but they
just maybe they have a boat
they just walk around with that [ __ ]
navy hat on
um
he was of that age
and what was killing me is i'm sitting
there going you know what i'm closer in
age to the [ __ ] navy hat guy
than uh
you know
the [ __ ] 20-somethings here whatever
anyways it was a [ __ ] great show and
uh so that's why the podcast was late so
you're probably thinking like wait a
minute bill that show probably started
at seven o'clock meaning you probably
left your house around six
game seven
chicago la kings that was at five
o'clock would you watch the first period
and leave no
i taped the game
listen to this [ __ ] this is how great it
is to be a hockey fan out in l.a i taped
game seven of the western conference
finals involving the los angeles kings
and the blackhawks of chicago
i go to the hollywood bowl there's like
what i don't know how many people is
that place hold ten fifteen thousand i
don't [ __ ] know
and i didn't have to worry about anybody
shouting out going hey it's two to one
two to one five minutes and ruining it
for me
all i did it was all i need to do was
shut up my phone so no one would send me
a text
and uh
i went to the concert i came home
i watched the first period
and by that point it was like one in the
morning and i was [ __ ] tired of [ __ ]
so i went to bed
and then i woke up this morning
and uh
i just watched the rest of it
this morning and like an [ __ ] i
didn't add time to it i don't know why i
always had time this is one time i
didn't i just hit record and i left so i
didn't have the overtime it looks like
he scored about six alec martinez scored
six minutes into the overtime my
condolences to all blackhawk fans
congratulations to all kings fans
and not to use the cliche but i'm going
to i'm going to use it there really are
no losers in a city like of course there
is a series like this of course there is
um
you know
because when you lose it sucks but i i
gotta tell you man like
if the nhl ever decided to put all seven
games of that series
on a dvd i would be one of the first
people to buy it because it was uh it
was that good top shelf
level hockey and all you [ __ ] [ __ ]
who watch hockey you know you watch the
gold medal game
you know once every four years you watch
one [ __ ] game
just imagine seven of those
that level of intensity except even more
because it's actually for a real trophy
okay they're not playing for a [ __ ]
necklace
you know with some bg's medallion
hanging off of it they're playing for
the [ __ ] stanley cup
that's what they all want to win they
would never say it
you can't say that in public what would
you rather do win the gold medal game
for your country or would you rather win
the [ __ ] chalice that they're gonna
put your name on it's a no-brainer
f my country i'm going to nashville and
i'm going to try to win the cup right
at least that's what i would think um
gives a [ __ ] about winning a gold medal
you know unless you're like your
cross-country ski with that rifle i mean
there's no way to go pro in that so that
that's your cup you got to do it but if
you're actually a professional athlete
right
you got a maserati sitting in your
[ __ ] garage
you know you got some hottie jumping on
your [ __ ] dick every night
do you really i mean i got a [ __ ]
gold necklace i'll go buy one
but you can't buy a stanley cup oh sure
you can make one out of cardboard and
tin foil and stand in the crowd
wearing a jersey looking like some giant
[ __ ] make-a-wish kid right now
that's not what these people play for
[Music]
this [ __ ] series was amazing if you
get a chance i don't know if nhl.com is
going to uh
is going to i mean i don't know they
have the highlights but they they
usually
i don't know how you do it i remember
back in the day when i used when i used
to live in boston what was cool over the
summer time was nessen
nessa network over the summer time they
used to have these these things called
uh a summer cooler
and over the summer they would play like
the best bruins games
of the year so the bruins would always
win the game it'd be some dramatic
victory and there'd be like a you know
bench clear and brawl or a big fight or
something like that it was great the
summer coolest so i don't know if
they're going to show it but whatever
um i got to tell you and somewhere along
the lines you know i was rooting for the
kings even though i still love chicago i
rooted for the kings because they were
the underdogs
and uh but then i was also going man
chicago
rangers
two original six i mean was the last
time they met each other in the uh
playoffs i mean the finals
i'm trying never in my lifetime as far
as i know 70s were a little weird
let's see the rangers got to the finals
in 79 and they played the canadians
and i don't think they got in the rest
of the time 76 was the [ __ ]
flyers lost to canadians
77-78 one of those was the bruins too
many men on the ice game when gila
floored the [ __ ] flower
um scored on the weakest [ __ ] wrist
shot you ever saw we nobody knew to go
down on the butterfly so the [ __ ] we had
was standing up a neck
and he did like a little [ __ ] flailed
at it with this [ __ ] pad
um
anyways let me just continue on oh by
the way i remember a long time ago i
gave a lot of today's hockey plays [ __ ]
because most of them hadn't even scored
50 goals and then i listened to dan
pratt's uh i recorded it because he had
wayne gretzky on
the great one and i actually listened to
it and gretzky said that he would have a
pro he would have problems scoring 50
goals
how good and how big
um the players are now and how great the
defenses are so i will shut the [ __ ] up
about that immediately
um
but anyways yeah so i started rooting
for the kings
you know i've just liked that team for a
number of years i just like how they
play and everything and i i just watched
a bunch of games and i somehow became a
fan and i was sitting out there this
morning watching the rest of the game
and somebody on the kings took a shot
and i like went like
i freaked out because he just missed it
then they scored a goal and i flipped
out and then nia just looked at me
and she just went shame on you
what did you abandon the boston bruins
and just put me in this defensive line
like no i didn't abandon him i was just
out you know i'm a fan of hockey i'm
rooting for the king she goes how can
you as a fan of any boston team
root for a [ __ ] la team and i was
like i know you're right
you're right i don't know how it
happened
you know
i actually was a fan of the los angeles
dodgers in the late 70s before the
lakers
celtics thing heated up in the 80s
and that was just because they hated the
yankees we could never beat them and
there was the bucky dead game so in 77
and 78 the dodgers played the [ __ ]
yankees so i'm not rooting for the
yankees so i would really root for the
dodgers and i became a dodgers fan
um
i love tommy lasorda right through when
they beat the yankees in 81. fernando
valenzuela when they beat the a's kurt
gibson hobbling around [ __ ] pumping
his fist all of that [ __ ] i was a
dodgers fan and then uh then i moved out
here and i went to a dodgers game you
know when i saw how [ __ ] their [ __ ]
fans are
they don't show up late they got a knife
to your throat i mean i'm exaggerating
but not really
kind of has like a little sort of biker
rally vibe
um
yeah i told you it's just i mean king's
fans are more mellow though but it's
just not it's
i don't know what it is about from
[ __ ]
san francisco on down out here on the
west coast these people
take it way too seriously if you have
the jersey of another team i mean it's
bad enough when you do that in other
parts of the country but this is the
last [ __ ] place i would come
wearing the jersey of the opposite team
there's no [ __ ] way
there's no [ __ ] way i like where my
nose is on my face i like my teeth i
like my my brain unswollen you know i
like not having little uh extra
breathing holes throughout my chest i
mean call me crazy
call me a [ __ ] i mean that's just just
just how i am
you know i'm at one time from some
[ __ ] celebrity
you know one of those those tough
celebrities you know they get movies and
they play enough tough guys that they
they start to think that they know how
to fight and save the world
was talking about wearing
another team's jersey to a laker game
they're like aren't you worried about
blah blah and he's like worried about
what like he says badass it's like [ __ ]
you with your
courtside seats
you know
walking in and out of the celebrity
entrance into your [ __ ] town car go
wear that in the upper deck
all right let's see if you live long
enough to do this sequel
to uh i am [ __ ] face part two right
all right well jesus bill you're in a
mood i am i'm a little tired and i ate
bad already today oh my god i ain't so
bad
do you know what last week
i got to mention this before i before i
do in the advertising was [ __ ]
hilarious i didn't even realize i said
it i was talking about something i said
oh god i'm such a gemini
i have never taken i don't that might
have been the most [ __ ] i ever took for
anything
that i said
on the podcast i must have got like
i don't know like 30 or 40
i retweeted a couple they
whoever wrote those you guys had me die
and laughing
just you know like when you say
something
and you that you don't even realize how
[ __ ] effeminate it is until somebody
brings it up and then it's just so bad
and the jokes are so good you can't do
anything but laugh i was like sitting by
myself
and the first one came in and this i
think that was the one i retweeted
somebody wrote
you know
i really had you i don't know something
about the level of respect they had for
me
you know was at a high level
and then it all went out the window the
second i said i'm such a gemini
and then i got like and i was just like
oh [ __ ] did i say that and i kind of
started laughing so i retweeted that one
and then i kind of scrolled down and
there was like 10 other ones
and each one was just more and more
brutal um so whatever that's a shout out
to whoever [ __ ] wrote those things
because
you guys gave me a great laugh this week
so
so why why why why not just
continue setting myself up to get
trashed here um you know what i did this
morning you know why the podcast is late
because this morning i was making
homemade cupcakes
[Music]
i swear to god
frosting and all that [ __ ] i was
frosting cupcakes when i was watching
the end
of a game seven nhl game the toughest
man sport
arguably out there i was frosting
cupcakes
you know what i stand by it and i don't
give a [ __ ] how much [ __ ] you guys give
me on twitter because i know you got it
because it's fun
but uh you know
what do you want from me it's my wife's
birthday today
one of her favorite things in the world
is uh she likes cupcakes with chocolate
frosting but out here they usually have
the chocolate frosting
with the chocolate cake
she likes the yellow cake with the
chocolate frosting myself included
all right insert interracial couple joke
there
um
so
you know i was i'm sick of driving
around trying to find him at [ __ ]
you know every goddamn bakery out here i
said [ __ ] it i'll make some
went out bought a couple of trays you
know what let me tell you something
about people who make cupcakes okay [ __ ]
them it's not that hard
it's not that hard i actually took out
my kitchenaid it's the second time i
used it one time i used it for [ __ ]
uh look at all this product placement
nhl.com kitchenaid i should start
getting paid for this [ __ ]
um
so i [ __ ] uh
i took that thing out for the first time
a couple months ago when i made some
homemade pop pasta
and uh this is the first time i used it
when i was actually baking it's the [ __ ]
it's like having an assistant that you
don't have to [ __ ] pay ever
things over in the corner just doing the
[ __ ] you don't want to do stirring it up
as you're doing some other [ __ ] i
gotta tell you something dead delicious
and everybody who wanted the wants to
give me [ __ ] i'm gonna tell you right
now
if i shove one down your pie hole you'd
have to say god damn it bill that's a
good cupcake i got to give it up to you
i don't respect you anymore as a man
that's a good goddamn cupcake so hey get
into the stanley cup finals here
the stanley cup finals
uh
i picked chicago to win it all wrong
i i crushed the first round you know
when the number one was playing the
eighth seed i called those all day after
the [ __ ] second round i mean into the
second round after the first rounds what
i'm trying to say i've just been
horrible
um so if i pick your team you should be
nervous
so right now ranger fans and kings fans
supposed to be saying if you believe in
that mojo [ __ ]
voodoo [ __ ] should be telling me to shut
up well you know what i'm not gonna
um i thought the canadians were gonna
beat the rangers and i thought the uh
i thought chicago was gonna beat the
kings
obviously neither that happened but i'll
tell you who picked it perfectly was joe
bartnick
joe bartnick said kings in seven games
the kings won in seven games at joe
bartnick
all right
okay you know if you wanna you're gonna
give a little tip of your cap go to joe
bartnik on the twitter
on the twitter uh app thing whatever the
[ __ ] you call it and i have a listen to
uh joe bartnik has his own podcast it's
all hockey talk
it's called puck off
um
and uh have a listen whatever the guy
the guy really knows his [ __ ] and he's
his biggest [ __ ] cam neely
so there you go um anyway so who am i
picking in the finals i think uh
i actually love both teams how [ __ ] up
is that i love a new york and an la team
i don't love their fans but i love that
team and uh just watching both of them
throughout the the last series i don't
know how you can hate either one of them
but i gotta go with the experience and i
got to take the [ __ ] la kings
you know two great goaltenders
you know what and i say bet the over in
all these games because everyone's gonna
think jonathan quick and [ __ ] uh
whatever the [ __ ] his name is suit
wearing lundqvist is it
henry henrik whatever the [ __ ] you call
uh they think that there's gonna be low
score and i don't think it's gonna be
i think they're gonna run into them i
think there's a lot of goalie masks
falling off
you know there's gonna be some upset
padded bearded gentlemen on both sides
of the ice going what the [ __ ]
you know um i just think it's gonna be a
great series and uh good luck to both
you i'm watching every second of it
so
this is your last series if you're gonna
ever gonna watch hockey
well i mean you can watch it again in
october but you know whatever come on
man jump on the [ __ ] bandwagon have a
good time all right
um
okay what else oh let me do some
advertising let me just knock these
things out shall we
where am i
where the [ __ ] is he advertising
all right there we go all right
note to host please personalize areas
highlighted in bold
you know i really get isn't it isn't
it's hard enough for me to read these
[ __ ] things
all right dollar shave club everybody
there are so many things that piss me
off
you know what sticking my hand into the
bowl like towards the end when i'm
trying to frost a cupcake and the
frosting gets on my knuckles and i have
to lick it off just knowing that that's
extra time i'm gonna spend on the
treadmill
you know but then i'm happy that i am
frosting a cupcake so you know it's kind
of i'm happy and sad you know i'm such a
gemini
um and paying way too much to shave my
face
is definitely up there nothing feels
better
than shaving with a fresh new blade
but new razors are so ridiculously
expensive that you can't afford to
change your blade more than once every
six months so you end up scraping up
your face with an old blade dollar shave
club delivers top quality razors for a
few bucks a month dollar shave club
members always shave with a fresh blade
because they get a fresh pack in the
mail um every month
talk candidly about your experiences
with the program well i lather up my
face and i use that fresh blade and when
i'm done i wash it off
and my face is as smooth as dr carver's
easy shave butter
um yeah they got lots of other great
products like the one i just mentioned
um and dr cave is post shave join the
hundreds of thousands of guys who've
upgraded to the smarter way to shave
shave time shave money join
dollarshaveclub.com
join now at
dollarshaveclub.com support this podcast
and a great company by going to
dollarshaveclub.com
one more time dollarshaveclub.com
that's burr also if you want to support
this podcast you can go to uh the
podcast page on billboard.com
and click on the amazon link and go
shopping
won't cost you any extra money and
they'll kick me a little do-ray me there
for sending you sending traffic their
way
all right um what's next
stamps.com everyone hey when you think
about the best time to go to the post
office you're probably guessing before
work after work or during lunch wrong
that's that's that's when it's the most
crowded well obviously nobody's at work
are they talking down to us at
stamps.com i don't think i like this um
everyone's going at that time the truth
is there's no convenient time to go to
the post office that's why you need
stamps.com actually in defense of them
that's the only time you can go if you
have a job right with stamps.com access
all the services of the post office
right from your own desk buy and print
official us postage for any letter or
package using your computer or your
printer
then just hand it over to the mail
carrier so easy and unlike the post
office stamps.com is open 24 7 with no
lines so you can get your mailing and
shipping done whenever it's convenient
for you i use stamps.com to send out all
my posters dvds whatever crap i'm
selling at the end of my shows i am a
[ __ ] and even i can figure out
stamps.com so if i can so can you how do
we do it well first of all special offer
right now use my name my last name burr
for this special offer no risk trial
plus 110 bonus offer that includes a
digital scale and up to fifty five
dollars free postage don't wait go to
stamps.com before you do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in bur b u r r
that stamps dot com enter bur
all right
oh i almost forgot to thank everybody
who came out to the improv
in uh arlington texas this week i had a
great time performing for you guys
getting ready to do my stand-up special
june 20th
at the tabernacle theater in atlanta uh
tickets are on sale right now
both shows looking like they're gonna
sell out so i want to thank everybody
that uh spent your hard earned cash to
watch me go dance around and tell my
jokes on the 20th
i'm really looking forward to it and um
i had a great time in dallas as always
big fan of texas and um and most of you
who listen to my podcast know
that i am a huge fan
of uh the discovery channel show fast
and loud the gas monkey garage guys so
i'm like i gotta go over there i gotta
go check this place out
and um
i went over to their garage they got a
gift shop over there with all these
t-shirts and stuff
and um
you know fortunately enough the uh the
owner richard was nice enough he was out
of town he had a few people over there
take me around
and um
i would i just i just had a great time i
saw all the cars
it was ridiculous i came walking in the
back total [ __ ] fanboy right actually
nervous as i'm walking in there i'm such
a fan of the [ __ ] show right
and uh i come walking in the back and
then it's like all these guys that i've
seen on the show and um
long story [ __ ] short long story
short i uh
i got to you know i got to see all these
cars some of the cars that they're
working on upcoming episodes i'm not
going to ruin anything that's coming up
but they're working on some of the
coolest cars that they've had since the
beginning of the episode and um
and then as i'm walking out in the
parking lot and there's casey's
uh that
army green f-100 that he has
frankenstein or whatever they call it a
lot of you guys who are fans of the show
watch them you know redo that truck
and um
i guess since they did it he put an even
faster engine in it long story short
the guy over there jason who was giving
me the tour who was really nice to me
the whole weekend um
he goes hey you want casey to give you a
ride in that truck
and i'm like man i don't want to bug the
guy of course i do but i don't want to
bug the guy i don't be some [ __ ]
jerk off i already met the guy he didn't
know who the [ __ ] i was right
so it's not like i could be like hey
i'll give you one of my [ __ ] stupid
stand-up dvds if you get i had nothing i
was just another jackass walking in
there
so he was cool as hell he goes yeah i'll
give you a ride so we start driving
around the block
in the truck he's talking to me about
the truck and all that type of [ __ ] and
we get on this straight away right
thank god they didn't film this they
they wanted to film it but they didn't
have any batteries in their camera they
want to stick one on the the windshield
dude it was the fastest [ __ ] thing
i've ever been in
he just
lets out the clutch and he just
we start flying down the street i can
literally feel the back end just ever so
subtly going left to right because
there's no weight in the back
and i'm s i felt like i was in a drag
racer and i was trying so hard to not
freak out and not be a [ __ ] but i'm not
gonna lie to you i had to put my i put
my foot up on the [ __ ] dashboard
because there was no seat belts and i'm
feeling this thing skating in the back
so we just go down the street
my [ __ ] face is contouring
and then he slows down
and i just go jesus [ __ ] christ what
are you trying to give me a heart attack
and he just you know his deadpan humor
just sort of laughs and he goes uh yeah
that was second gear
second gear we're going like 70 miles an
hour down this little ass [ __ ] road
cars parked on both sides
um it took it literally took me about
four hours to come down from probably
the three seconds that we were driving
that fast but uh
i got to do that how cool is that how
cool are the people at gas monkey that
they actually uh took time out of their
day to let me do that um
huge fan of the show i went over to
their bar
they got their own restaurant over there
it's like the number two live place to
play music now in texas already or in
dallas they just passed house of blues
they're [ __ ] crushing it over there
so
um
i don't know if you get a chance
i i'd man i asked all kinds of geeky fan
questions too i'm trying to remember
some that won't ruin any episodes they
get like 400 emails a day because i ask
them like how do you guys find how do
you find all these [ __ ] cars
i know richard's always saying i'm going
to go on the interweb and blah blah they
get 400 emails a day
of people
with these cards that they want to sell
either they don't want to handle them or
the person who owned them passed away
and um
man you should see so i
i got to shut up because i don't want to
ruin any of so thank you to richard
rawlings for hooking me up over there
casey for giving me the ride and uh
jason um and his lovely wife linda
giving me the tour and everything i i
just had a great great time and i can't
wait for the next season so uh
if you don't watch it fast and loud on
discovery look at that that was like a
[ __ ] 20-minute commercial form
um all right let's let's move on to the
uh
to the questions this week
ever so are slightly 36 minutes in okay
uh solar panels
last week i talked about i was thinking
about maybe getting solar panels off my
house
off my house on my house
and uh
i don't know if i want to go off the
grid but whatever
i sit here bacon in the sun in this
[ __ ] house i might as well get
something out of it right
all right so here we go hi bill first
off huge fan of your comedy podcast
thank you i saw you perform brian regan
well with brian regan cubs comedy wow
that was a that was a bucket list night
for me to be able to perform with that
guy
show was absolutely hilarious well thank
you and thank you from brian regan too
anyway regarding your question about
solar there is no solar power that is
completely off the grid you use all the
energy that you can provide through
solar and the rest that can't be
provided by the sun
like at night
or if it gets shady on your roof the
utility provides this is called
interconnection
uh you save a ton of money and you use
clean energy in the process i work for a
solar company i promise this isn't a
[ __ ] sales pitch and i manage the
construction timeline so i've learned a
lot about this stuff here's a link to my
company i work for we install a lot in
la and in boston as well too i think
we're in like 12 different states
anyways thank you for the awesome
podcast hey you know something about
this solar [ __ ] this
every person you talk to says something
different
i watch people on youtube
make up a solar thing um
what a solar thing put up their solar
panels broke down how they worked
and uh and how you could get off the
grid but it was really really really
[ __ ] involved this guy's digging a
goddamn trench i can't even what the
[ __ ] was going on but i'm just like all
right i don't have room for a trench all
right my little piece of property here
so i don't you know
i got room for a hole does that work
i can't even what he was doing they dug
this trenching stuff like a [ __ ] tarp
in there
i don't even know what that i can't even
tell you what's going on but um
i will definitely uh i'll definitely
look into it
um hopefully i'll have more luck with
you guys than the [ __ ] [ __ ] who put
the roof on this house
[ __ ] [ __ ] i told you what they
did right they put the roof on the house
and then like the drain pipes because
it's an old house old stupid design
where the drain off was it goes down
into a pipe that actually goes into like
a i don't i have like a
my attic is actually you ever see seeing
john malkovich or being
being john malkovich remember they had
that floor we had to walk around bent
over like that's basically how much
space there is
between um
the ceiling on my top floor
and then the roof
i don't even know what the purpose of it
is all it is is just it just traps air
that gets heated up and causes my house
to be hot but anyways that's what it is
so the drain off of the water on the
roof
goes into a pipe that goes in
into the [ __ ]
crawl space and then back out the front
of the house and down the side
so you take water from the roof you
bring it into the house
it's inside a pipe but nevertheless you
bring it into the [ __ ] house
and god forbid
that pipe bursts or you have some
[ __ ] [ __ ] who disconnects it when
he's putting the new roof on and forgets
to hook it back up
and then tries to blame it on yeah he
blamed it oh you know the [ __ ] old
and blah blah blah and i'm just sitting
there going all right this is at least a
year in court you know what why don't
you just get the [ __ ] out of here
i'll just put in a goddamn claim you
[ __ ] that's what i did because i didn't
want to go to court so um
anyways i'm hoping you're better than
those guys
i mean how couldn't you be
all right here's my favorite one of this
week uh solar roadways debunked
um
i got a note from my guy here andrew
says a ton of people forwarded the same
link
as uh the one in the email below i watch
this so you don't have to it's 30
minutes long
basically he [ __ ] about cost
maintenance and the efficiency of
efficiency of the perks advertising
original video like heating repairing
the road yeah i actually watched the
first 10 minutes of it
i'll save my opinion until i read this
uh yo billy the sunburn kid i know you
were pretty pumped up about solar roads
to be honest so was i but someone smart
sat down and crunched some numbers and
brought up points as well as to why
solar roads are economically and tech
technically not feasible it's about 30
minutes long so if you got some time to
kill in any airport check it out well
you know what sir i watched the first
ten minutes of it
uh he didn't debunk them he just brought
up a bunch of questions
he's just like a road has to be durable
and i would have some questions about
i mean they showed a tractor run over
the tiles but it was a small tractor and
they only did it once
um i i would like to see how these
you know these things hold up when it's
wet out and
you need water to run off and he just
brought up a bunch of [ __ ] questions
you know he didn't debunk them he did
basically basically what he did
it's like 50 percent what you have to do
you can't have somebody just coming in
hey these are brand new roads can i make
them oh okay
you you think they're good you think
they're gonna work okay i mean obviously
you can't do that
but it's 50 that which is smart you got
to ask the right questions and then the
other side
is anytime you try to do something new
there's always people saying it's not
going to work you know
and this guy
in his half hour i'm sure he bring he
brought up a number of things that would
be a problem it doesn't mean they can't
work
okay so i don't i wouldn't say they were
debunked i would just say somebody asked
a bunch of [ __ ] questions
and
rather than just when what he does is he
just throws it out there it's like why
don't you contact the people at the
solar road
who trying to make the solar roads and
actually get some answers and get some
[ __ ] uh or maybe order some tiles and
try to do some experiments yourself
rather than wasting people's
time with the half hour of questions and
speculation that's basically what it was
so i wouldn't say that it was debunked
um but you know you throw up three
pointers for a half an hour some of them
are going to go in even if you suck so
i'm sure a couple of his concerns were
true
but uh you know i mean look at electric
cars
since way back in the day people they
shook they're [ __ ] up like people
actually question the power of elect
electricity
it powers the entire [ __ ] city can
light up a whole [ __ ] city and i get
a prius and my own mother my own
mother
is going can it go up a hill
no mom i just gotta get out and start
walking
it's great for my weight
and look at that they saw they're
underpowered and they're this and that
first of all the prius is not an
electric car
it's not even a [ __ ] 50 electric car
it's like an eight percent electric car
that's what it is
from like zero i've told you this guys
for years from zero to seven miles an
hour that car runs on electric power and
then switches over to gas for the rest
of the time and if you drive with a lead
foot you're gonna get maybe 25 miles a
gallon but if you listen if you listen
to the engine
okay and you don't stomp on the gas and
drive like a [ __ ] maniac and slam on
the brakes you can get you know i don't
i wouldn't say 40 miles a gallon you can
get like 35 but it's great
perfect car if you're living in the city
i absolutely love the [ __ ] thing so
anyway so you had that i bought that
thing in october of 2007
and now
look at these these tesla cars i
actually wrote in one of those uh the
end of last year
before i wrote in casey's [ __ ] truck
jesus christ which probably gets two
feet to the gallon especially the way he
was driving it
um
those tesla cars are are [ __ ] amazing
and you can drive from last i checked
from san diego all the way up to
vancouver um
you know they have recharge stations
from san diego all the way up to
vancouver and i think recently someone
just drove one across the country so
i sound like that guy in the speculation
video um i gotta look that one up or you
should look it up or whatever but um i'm
actually uh i'm leaning towards that
[ __ ] thing
things bad ass you walk up to and you're
turning on like the door handles are
flush against the car and you walk up
and things pop out
i'm sure other cars do that but i never
seen it you know
it's cool to me the only thing i didn't
like about the car is it has like a
super sized [ __ ] ipad
right in the dashboard
um and that just seemed like that would
be really distracting for somebody like
me i need like a shade just to sort of
pull that thing down but um
i'm actually thinking of maybe getting
one
i also kind of like the idea that
they're just sort of one price like you
know going there and there's none of
that haggling
um so you don't feel like a [ __ ] when
you walk out because i don't give a [ __ ]
how many [ __ ] videos you watch you
still get your ass handed to you um but
either way let's bring in the birthday
girl hey nia
come on in
gotta bring in the birthday girl over
here
um
let me try to find something
that she can relate to nba oh bill
not asking you to rant for 20 minutes
oh there we go the lovely near everybody
happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you
happy birthday dear
[Laughter]
happy birthday to you
ah
yeah sorry that was beautiful oh it was
in its own
sad way
um how'd you like your cupcake i loved
it there you go you made me a cupcake my
favorite kind of cupcake too which is
very sweet you taste it right put a
little candy put a little candle roll a
candle in it
happy birthday horrible that was very
nice and you didn't mush it in my face i
did it all right well happy birthday a
whole bunch more that you made so you
know
well that's the thing all my recipes
stay on your p's and q sweetheart
well the thing is
is all my recipes come from my mother
so they all serve like 10 people so
right well most cupcake recipes are
going to be for
like they make more than 30.
yeah i stopped after i went two rounds
through what did i make was it's
what was it was this six in a tray or
eight in a tray yeah there's like 18 or
20 of them out there yeah well nobody
makes one cupcake so yeah any kind of
recipe is gonna why don't you just make
like like six
six is perfect they never think about
like they don't they never think about
the lonely people
when they make a cookbook well the thing
is you could put
enough batter in for six and cook the
sticks and then freeze the rest of your
batter and just have it for the next
time you want to make cupcakes so it's
not like it's a complete waste
but oh all right who's going to give you
the exact measurements for like one or
two cupcakes that's that's silly well
you know
i think
that'd be a great idea for a cookbook
what
cupcakes for one no the loner the loner
cookbook the loner
or like you're single
yeah like when you're [ __ ] single
yeah sitting there trying to do the math
you know it serves eight it's just like
i'm [ __ ] 22 i'm trying to make
spaghetti over here
why don't they just make it but that's
why you have luck but the thing is
that's why it's good to have leftovers
you freeze the [ __ ] and you have it for
later well it's not it's not bad now
because you can go on the internet like
today
i'm sitting there looking at that
[ __ ] cane sugar
and
they're asking me
in the bag it says two pounds of cane
sugar
and they wanted a certain amount of
ounces
and i'm sitting there and all i have is
like a quarter cup so i go i was like
how many cups are in a pound and they're
like well cups is more of a like a
size yeah not a size what is the word
like like uh
they couldn't figure like it's not a
weight a cup is not a weight it's more
like a [ __ ] handful kind of looking
at like that so
what i actually did was i took out one
of your little sports [ __ ]
things that you drink out of that has
ounces on the side so the protein shakes
in yes that works yeah well that's why
the thing was a disaster
once i got it it looked like a bakery
exploded in there yeah flour everywhere
yep mix this like kicked on the the
countertops on the floor and dry little
white puddles
that's right
you're like a little kid whenever you go
like something you make the biggest
[ __ ] mess i have ever seen the
kitchen is a disaster that's why i like
it you've got like stains all over your
apron you know you're sweating a little
bit
you're hairy you're like flipping around
in your socks in the kitchen
sliding around in flower you're all like
stressed out you're all red in the face
i wasn't stressed out you weren't
stressed out this time but other times
you've bathed stuff it's been funny
that's when i i've learned to stay away
well here's the kitchen no no here's the
thing that was that was the younger me
who flipped out
no i didn't flip out a year ago
just quit going for the joke come on i'm
getting better
um
yeah and also back in the day i didn't
have an apron you gotta have an apron
you gotta have a neighborhood apron your
fans are all messy just yeah right in
the front of them and you just you just
just keep marching forward
you leave the casualties behind you it's
[ __ ] phenomenal
um it was delicious though i really
appreciate it and your gifts were
amazing of course they were you killed
at this birthday of course i did and you
know what you know i killed it because
you always figure out what i'm going to
get you is i just played like i was a
[ __ ] i really hate that though can i
just say i really you drove me crazy
with that yesterday you were driving me
nuts you were actually mad at me that
was i was trying not to be but you were
really pushing my butt and you were
trying to make me mad see that's the
thing
you're toying with me though huh you
know exactly what i'm talking about i
emailed you something like a month ago
just saying hey if you're wondering what
to give me for my birthday because i
know you're busy i know you're on the
road and all this other stuff look at
you actually help you
out i'm telling you what i want also you
know it's like i'm not like a little kid
you know what i mean i don't tell you
exactly what i want to like give you
lead you in the right direction what a
little kid say that what say what they
don't want well i mean you know you
there's a little kid has a breath that
you're like yeah i have a toy
get out of here beat it but when you're
older is that what happens that's like
specific things that you know maybe
you'd like to guess you let people know
my parents ask me all the time what do
you want for your birthday what do you
want for your birthday because nobody
has time to sit around and like figure
out what do you want so you know isn't
that what i did this year but that's
what you did because you took what i
wanted and then you kind of riffed on it
and you got a bunch of stuff
to surround no it was it was wonderful
but my point is you made me cry i don't
like that you still took credit you took
what i said and then you rift on it and
i did i actually listened to you this
year
and i from months ago and i figured out
what the [ __ ] you wanted and then you
did your usual thing because you are an
organizing
you like you you just you're an
organized person
literally to the point that you're
organizing my shopping for what i get
you now one of the great things about
giving somebody a gift is the surprise
where they're like not a surprise take
me out to brunch and you're like all
right i gotta get you home cause i gotta
go shopping for your birthday like the
how's that supposed to make me feel i'm
sitting there like uh okay this is why
this is why i did that because you
emailed me something i knew you wanted
this [ __ ] yes okay now if i just went
out and got it for you i mean why don't
i just [ __ ] when the mailman comes he
hands it to me and then i throw it at
you when you're sitting there takes no
[ __ ] imagination whatsoever right so
i knew you wanted it i knew i was gonna
get it for you but i'm like how the [ __ ]
is it still a surprise that she gets it
so what i did was i acted like i wasn't
and i already knew the other things that
i was gonna i was gonna get i knew where
the hell they were i waited to the last
second to get it so you thought i was
like a an unthoughtful jackass and it
worked like a [ __ ] charm why would
you but why would you make yourself seem
like you know a last minute jackass like
that like why would just to torture me
and i'll tell you what torture me
because you can't just give me the gift
and be like here you go honey you have
to have some other little thing where
you throw me off my game you get me all
in the tizzy and then it's like oh wait
he actually did the perfect thing why
why do you play those because that's
exactly the type of things that you
accuse women of doing and you do it to
me all the time
this is why
because when i don't do that you guess
exactly what i'm going to get you and
it's [ __ ] annoying
it's [ __ ] and i wrap something you
already know what's in it you make me
feel like an idiot
why do you feel like an idiot just
because i guess what it is you don't
guess you peak you look that time when i
came when i went christmas shopping oh
my god
yes we are yes we are
yes we are did not
see what you brought this is when you
know you're going to bring up a good
point with your woman and she
immediately starts trying to talk over
you i do the same thing yes you do so
i'm pulling up in the car you knew i was
going christmas shopping for you i'm
getting out of the car i open the
hatchback to our sweet innocent little
hybrid right
i take the bag out that has the name of
the [ __ ] store and i glanced
and i glanced over at the house and
you're standing there like a specter
looking out the window
my [ __ ] heart my heart like jolted
when i looked up you you know you had a
creepy look on your face you were doing
something sneaky i was like waving at
you no you weren't and then you didn't
see me can i show you can i show you
what you were doing you have all right
this is what you were doing i looked
when i i'm looking at the house and i
look up at you like this
nobody can see me so what you're sitting
there looking like some weird like
stalkers that's what you were doing no i
did it that's what you were doing you're
a spoiled brat and you you wanted to see
what was in the thing spoiled brat
all right you're spoiled
because you spoil me
oh god blaming the victim once again
victim no here's a deal
no that's why i did it
i'd like to try to surprise you if i'm
going to spend all my [ __ ] money on
on some goddamn thing here i want you to
i i i
i want i want to see
to throw how much money it costs for you
to start the present in my face you
didn't have to say how much it cost just
by saying if i'm going to am i really
going to lose this am i going to lose
this one it's my birthday so yeah oh my
god
all right let's go
it's because let's get back to this
yeah because it's like a sport for you
to figure out what the [ __ ] i got you
it's annoying i never tried for you to
always throw me off my game you know
it's a sport for me teaching you how to
use a microphone just talk into it oh
okay there you go
you couldn't hear me before well i hear
you and then you're over here
no you only go over here when you're
imitating somebody else that's what you
do or when you go lady yeah there you go
that's all it is that's the mic
technique there you go all right we're
going to talk nba here nini
the nba the nba national basketball
association i know it's a professional
league now with basketball william i
know what it is unlike soccer you use
your hands but not your feet you can't
kick the ball
it's reverse soccer i'm just wondering
what i'm going to possibly know about
the nba but anyway let's let's let's go
ahead and read it well i mean i have to
read the questions here okay
there's no penalty in just
tapping out on one
nba bill not asking you to rant for 20
minutes on this because i know not
everyone cares about basketball but
the nba
the nba is so rigged how can announcers
and former players not be up in arms
lebron got three fouls in the first
quarter i hate lebron but christ let's
have a fair game i think the trick is to
watch shitty teams and hope shitty teams
make it to the playoffs so there's no
incentive to sway the momentum if the
raptors played the jazz and the
championships there's no superstars
uh
help or to help or to penalize yeah i
mean i think it's
look in any sport
the top players definitely get
preferential treatment i mean there's
the tom brady rule there's there's all
kinds of [ __ ] that goes on but i just
you know that's one of those ones where
look i mean they make more money if it
goes more games
it's i just i just feel like
i've already said what i said okay i'm
not going to keep reiterating it either
you believe it or you don't i know for
years i said it was fixed and then they
found a mobbed up ref
you know who was actually fixing games
and [ __ ] the sacramento kings out of a
series against the lakers and the lakers
went on to win a championship they
literally affected who the [ __ ] won the
championship that year or this guy did
and then everybody when i was vindicated
and i was right just when like uh
it was just one guy
it's just one guy i think it's in their
best interest
to have the stars of the big teams
in the finals and for to go
more than four games
okay and i think you know
those refs get paid by the game those
[ __ ] uh arenas you know more games
more concession more tickets
more commercial more money
so and i think that uh that plays a
[ __ ] role consciously or
subconsciously i'm not saying that they
sit down i just think that it's [ __ ]
i just i my thing i'm done saying it's
fixed i'll just say that the reps have
way too much power and they have to stop
dictating that the tempo of the game i
would like the players
you know i would rather have that all
right there we go
but either way don't blow in lebron's
ear even though that was funny as
[ __ ] hell did you see that no this
guy on uh
on the [ __ ] pacers i forget his name
not a big hoop guy right he blew in
lebron's yeah they were sitting there
i think they they were both sitting
there you know when you got your hands
on your knees i don't know if they're
waiting for a jump ball or something
right and he was sort of not quite
perpendicular to the side of lebron's
face but he just sort of went
right into his ear and what was funny
was it took lebron for like half a
second then he sort of smiled and shook
his head like
so it didn't have the desired effect
where he was hoping he was going to get
like when will smith slap that guy who
kissed him
i think he was trying to get him off his
game flappable lebron james
well i mean he's like he's unflapping
he's like a [ __ ] x-man out there the
guy's a goddamn superhero although i
gotta tell you i i get so turned off by
the nba i don't understand what all this
screaming and yelling is after you make
a basket
what do you mean screaming like they're
excited like they're like no like
they're mad at somebody you can't see
they're yelling just they're looking at
the crowd yelling
lebron james took the ball went coast to
coast like i've seen my entire life he's
not the first guy to go coast to coast
he dunks the ball and when he's done he
first walks and he starts glaring at the
crowd and then he's going all the way up
the sideline
[Music]
is he just like all hyped and like yeah
yeah i i like
what they always hyped weren't you
always hyped you gave a high five
he's sitting there screaming and yelling
thumping his [ __ ] chest they're out
there acting like they're it's like dude
you put a ball through a hoop
i know you you're the one of the
greatest who ever [ __ ] did it but you
you're not jordan i never saw jordan do
that
so what he doesn't have to be jordan
he's the one i'm just saying why i don't
like i'm not saying he can't do it
dude kevin garnett i swear to god it's
like he has tourette's
he does anything he's walking up to the
line like talking to himself and every
other word is [ __ ]
and you can clearly see that the guy's
saying [ __ ]
and i don't understand i just it's it's
bizarre every other word out of your
mouth is [ __ ]
yeah no but i'm not on [ __ ] teeth oh
i guess i am on tv yes you are on tv
and no no no no that's i'll tell you why
this is different that would be like if
i told the joke and then it killed and
as the crowds laughing and applauding i
would stand up to go yeah [ __ ]
that's how you tell the joke i ain't
playing in this show
it's stupid
just do your job and shut the [ __ ] up
yeah it's stupid
that's the difference all right
that's and that's why
my thing is
i can't like
like you're you're applauding yourself
you're more if i can't even get to the
level of amazement that they are about
themselves
that's what turns me off about the
[ __ ] game
you ever recatch her in the ryanair oh
my god
that [ __ ] catcher on the rye analogy
you always make i'll tell you why
because always with the catch in the rye
that's that that [ __ ] thing when he
sees that great piano player but the guy
knows he's great he's making that face
that ge smith thing and it's just like
yeah dude you're up your own ass right
now you don't need me and i'm not going
to sit there and watch you [ __ ] jerk
yourself off after you just did
something that a bunch of other people
have already [ __ ] done and it drives
me
it drives me [ __ ] nuts and all i know
is that little kids see it now and then
they're going to be doing that you can
go to little kids games and they get
[ __ ] take like a diaper shot and then
go yeah
high pitched voice coach on the [ __ ]
thing and i'm gonna sit there i'm gonna
i'm gonna want to throw a hot dog at him
you really are an old foggy now with
your complain about how these young kids
go out there they're thumping their
chest in there just go out there and do
your job yeah i mean i look there's
definitely an element of that i'll even
take sixty percent of that but forty
percent of it as i'm right what are you
doing
i never s magic johnson never did that
[ __ ] jordan didn't do it but they talk
[ __ ] to each other
right occasionally you know they'd be
executive you didn't turn around glare
at the crowd
like like like you just [ __ ] defeated
somebody on planet krypton and then
[ __ ]
go down the side and scream dude
screaming and yelling that's where the
cameras though with this crazy maybe
it's for the maybe it's for the cameras
and maybe it's for he looked like a
trick you know you know you know when
the crazy homeless guy gets on the
subway and he just starts yelling and
then you just look down at the floor
going please don't pick me please don't
pick me don't look at them those are the
rules are they doing it for the clips
when they do like the commercials where
they play the music and stuff and they
show all the clips from the games they
show the guys like yeah like looking out
the crowd maybe it's for that of course
it is playing up
they all hang out with each other in the
same [ __ ] yacht and go hey let's all
jump on the same team and then we'll
become a dynasty and then you know then
the announcers who make money announcing
the nba so they're never going to
criticize it and then they just say the
same they'll tell you when you get
mentioned in the same breath of
magic johnson or or michael jordan
because they are accomplishing the same
thing on paper
but they're not doing what those guys
did and when those guys did it you did
it through the draft and maybe a
blockbuster trade
okay there was way more cerebral back
than how you had to put it together a
team you had to lean way more on your
[ __ ] scouts you didn't have a bunch
of players all jump on the same team and
then you jump on this team
okay
he jumps on this [ __ ] team
and becomes like this three-headed
[ __ ] monster
just stomping on all these other goddamn
t i mean why don't i just watch you go
[ __ ] go play a bunch of kids
a high school team i mean i know it's
not that bad but it did that that's
what's killing it for me okay
yeah you know do you want funny you're
not even a sports fan whatever you know
you're not so why did you call me in for
this
one woman why'd i call you and you said
you wanted to come on the podcast i said
yeah cause i want to talk about other
things not the nba
[Laughter]
all right office [ __ ]
is that it is that a good one it sounds
like something that you would want me to
just because it has [ __ ] in it like oh
let's get a ladies opinion in here okay
what does it say oh this is a long
you're unbelievable i just did the nba
that's a guy topic you didn't like that
one so now i'm giving you a lady tucker
no i want to hear this one i want to
hear this one i'm with you i want you
you didn't sound like you were you saw
me get back pedaling i'm with you okay
all right
this guy writes billy parmesan and then
writes pronounced parmesan like i don't
know how to read parmesan
why what do i say parmesan
from john parmesan parmesan billy
parmesan i'm italian and very much so
at that i speak italian and
i'm first generation italian ciao this
guy italian prego
i work with a girl who claims she's
italian but she really isn't at all
hashtag middle eastern
um i mean
how does he
i mean her grandmother may have [ __ ] a
sicilian oh or
she's olive garden italian you know less
than 1 16th italians are not [ __ ]
around about who's italian he's not
italian and if you're sicilian it's like
a different thing
yeah you guys don't play with that they
don't [ __ ] around the same way gas
monkey does not [ __ ] around when they
build a car i told them that story right
in casey's truck jesus christ um anyways
in the office she is constantly uh
calling me and a few other italians
guineas and goombas
she says it like she's one of us and
most times in a manner that really
forces it into the conversation like hey
guineas don't grease up my stapler now
i'm not completely insulted but the
catch is she's black
a year ago she complained to human
resources that a co-worker who would
listen to rap music on his headphones at
lunch would mouth lyrics that weren't
meant for him i.e the n-word there
really is no proof that he even mouthed
the words because he sat facing the wall
and all she knew was that he was
listening to jay-z's new album at the
time and assumed he mowed all the words
none of which were audible by the way
um how do you know this if you weren't
there um so one day last week she was
calling us dumb guineas and asked if my
friend leonardo yes that is his name if
he could wring out his hair over herself
oh my god
because the place she ordered from
didn't give her enough dressing to go on
her salad wow wow that is a funny joke
though if you're if you're cool with
somebody that's [ __ ] hilarious uh the
funny thing because those are the rules
horribly offensive if you're not if
you're not yeah because that's one of
the things if you're friends
if someone was you know some italian guy
was breaking my balls for being a pasty
freckled [ __ ] and then i came up with
that ring your hair out of the salad i
mean that's that's [ __ ] i might have
him for the week he'd have to come back
with the i don't know what uh the funny
thing about the situation is that leo
doesn't have greasy hair at all well
yeah i mean it's a huge stretch of a
joke and a stereotype it's hacky and not
even insulting the insulting part is
that she thinks nothing of it i know
what you're gonna say this is one of
those things you just gotta let go but i
didn't i stood up and said listen you're
not italian if you're italian then i'm
black because i'm sicilian and we've all
heard the true romance speech that was
the end of it did i handle that right
because i sure as hell wasn't going to
let myself become
an hr [ __ ] uh thanks for listening um i
think you did the right thing because
first i know you know why did you go
first nate what do you what do you think
no i actually think he did the right
thing too because
the girl says she's italian but you say
she's black but like
just meaning like she looks black like
she looks like me or like she's actually
has said i am black and italian because
maybe she's biracial or whatever so
i mean the whole thing about she's not
really italian
that's why i was laughing at how
italians are very you know protective
about who can say they're italian and
who's not so she might be biracial right
but the thing about it is you know in
this country they have that whole like
what is it
the one eighth whatever drop paper bag
test all that kind of [ __ ] where it's
like if you've got a drop of black blood
in you
you're black that's the way it's
considered in this country that's the
way it was set up in america so maybe
that's why you're feeling like you're
not even italian you're black so that
all aside yeah for her i'm making a joke
saying like dumb guineas and goombas and
stuff like if you're offended by you
should definitely tell her i'm offended
by that i know you said you're italian
but i just i find that kind of speech
you know offensive so please don't say
it around me i don't like that and i
think that is better i didn't think it
is better to confront the person than
running off to hr
you know the whole thing with the guy
mouthing the lyrics to jay-z's album and
he was facing the wall like listen yeah
unless you were there i mean he probably
had a conversation with this guy that's
why he's coming out like that she said i
was melting the n-word and she couldn't
even see me i said i mean but here's the
thing here's the thing this is the thing
she this is the deal
right and this thing all those jokes are
funny if it's done the right way and
she's not doing it the right way and if
she look i think if she came to this guy
and said hey um whatever 1 8th italian
or whatever
and talked about
italians in a respectful way
that this guy would embrace her that she
would that her italian blood and then
they would have this bond where he'd be
like ah that's the italian in you see i
knew but if you come at him that way if
you start going hey if you [ __ ] [ __ ]
uh right right quit reaching up the
floors over here yeah that whole thing
about give me some of your hair because
i don't have enough i got to tell you
hilarious that's [ __ ] funny i can't i
can't read that without laughing yeah
but it's funny but no it's it's it's
wrong over to say that especially if
she's gonna turn around and be upset
that someone's listening to rap music in
their headphones and mouthing words that
don't words that aren't for you yeah
jay-z will take jay-z will take your
white money you'll take your white money
but that those lyrics are not for you
know this
i will you you and all your friends can
finance my next big purchase but these
lyrics are not for you uh what is the
rule on that can a white guy
in his car
can sing a log
right to the rap music i'm not going to
tell you which one star
what is what would you say as an
african-american is the protocol if
you're singing along i mean it's just a
song you know sunshine
on my shoulders
makes me happy are you allowed to say
the end of the front yeah but then what
rap song so so somebody's already
singing a song okay you're on a bus
right mm-hmm it's a terrible day for you
now you're on a bus oh jesus where you
going what happened um as long as i'm
not in the back i'm all right um
so somebody's got their little [ __ ]
ipod on right
or phone thing whatever right and
they're singing
to the songs right and the first song
they're singing is that you know
sunshine oh my you're laughing like wow
this guy's singing out loud he's singing
off-key you're kind of laughing to
yourself but he's got his ipod on
shuffle
okay
and then the next one is that wu-tang
song right and he's singing along to old
dirty bastard shame on a tried to run
game on a who's [ __ ] wild and he starts
singing along with that i think you
should do it just the way you did it
do it the way
i feel like the silence listen when we
when i went to go see jay-z
would you guess that no but at this this
is a good example of that when to go see
jay-z and kanye the watch the throne at
the staples center
you know whole stadium arena full of
people all black white whoever
and everybody was singing along to all
the songs and it wasn't
in the context of it it was like yeah
because it's not like the white people
are going to be like oh i can't it's
like we're all singing along it's all
enjoying the music it's not a big deal
so if there's a big crowd of people
singing the n word well i mean i feel
like there's a difference between that
than the white person who's like trying
to show you how down they are and
they're like all in your what do you
call that again appropriating the what
do you call it oh cultural appropriation
yes yeah if you're like a white person
that's like yeah i'm down for my [ __ ]
you know how we [ __ ] do with it i'm
gonna look at you like you're [ __ ]
crazy
i'm gonna do that
to like tomorrow know it's it's it's
ridiculous for you to do that but it
used to shock me in new york when i
would hear these kids that were
seemingly now i'm like the guy that
wrote in not black but like latin like
you know dominican or puerto rico puerto
ricans and they call themselves [ __ ]
all the time and i wasn't aware of that
when i first moved to new york so i was
like what and then i just realized yeah
that's they they do that too i remember
so it's okay for them i remember when i
was an in-n-out
burger uh sitting outside the one on uh
sunset boulevard and i was sitting there
and there was this dude i think he was
mexican
which once again he's probably middle
eastern they get they get they get
mistook for everything
mexicans no middle eastern people oh yes
once they once they get out of the uh
stereotypical god damn it it's 110
degrees out here i'm going to wear this
robe thing when they just start where
when they start
no i'm talking to middle east oh oh okay
once they once when they wear
americanized [ __ ] clothes okay they
can go
oh yeah because they're then they're
just brown
i know i knew a guy for years
i thought he was italian and on stage he
was pretending to be italian right
and it turned out he was lebanese
i had no idea no idea he had the [ __ ]
you know wasn't there another famous
comedian who kind of had an italian
persona and it turns out that he's
actually jewish gee i don't know nia is
there
um all right
just [ __ ] set me up here
um all right let's go to uh here we go
uh dear billy goat i was listening to
all some old podcasts
and uh you were sharing your feelings on
movies you'd recently seen what was the
last movie theater experience you
enjoyed i mean the movie itself
not all the necking that goes on in the
back row you old bloodhound
oh he's using those old words just this
is just him acting like i'm [ __ ] old
um all right the last movie in the
theater
well i probably would i would have saw
it with you i'm not a big one wall
street was the last one we saw in the
theater oh my god which i hated hated
hated hated hated
i gotta tell you this it was worth
seeing leonardo's the the actress that
played his wife jesus margot robbie
she's gorgeous she's australian did you
know that
uh
no
i just don't know
she was like
you know what's great about her was she
was totally naked and she still it
didn't it didn't look dirty she was just
she was a goddess
gorgeous okay
i mean nia when i look at her yeah
i got it but did you like the movie
that's what he wants to know was your
your the last time you were in a movie
and really enjoyed the movie itself
was it
i don't i can't remember what we saw in
the movie theater before that because i
feel like we very rarely go to the movie
theater all right we must have saw
something since then
well for wall street i have to see again
why because it was can suck another
eight hours out of your life jesus it
wasn't that bad it was definitely long
it was too long and it was like
repetitive it's like i get it these guys
are drug taking [ __ ] how many more
scenes is this do we need
and it's like i appreciate the chemistry
between leonardo dicaprio and jonah hill
but it's like all right already he just
you know scorsese just let the camera
run and run and run and run and i will
say that some of those sales meetings
were so long i started to feel like i
worked at the company i thought that
they were they were kind of uh
in real time they were really trying to
hammer home the fact that these were
just these underhanded
dirty
kind of excessive 80s guys and it's like
we got it the opening shot was them
tossing them
we live in this world now we get who
they are you know what i do want to see
i want to see that i don't know how to
say it though maleficent
yeah i kept saying male 1 male 1
she kept seeing mailings maleficent
that's not a word right it's the name of
the character it's the name of the evil
queen in snow white that's her name is
it latin for something i have no idea
all right dear billy goat
i was listening some old to some old
podcast
and you were just read that
oh
you're just [ __ ] crazy i didn't even
i didn't even realize that p.s i loved
x-men he said and uh please remind
listeners
oh
oh okay hey listen please remind uh
family listeners that which family
member would you [ __ ] dilemmas are hacky
and won't make it to the podcast yeah
yeah why would you even ask a question
like that there's because some people
want to have sex with a [ __ ] family
member and they want to feel like
they're not alone in this world they do
i don't know all right oh they're just
doing it i hate those weird like would
you rather
[ __ ] your mother
or [ __ ] your dog like what
oh i don't you even
without a doubt well it depends on
depends on what kind of dog it is
how much fight does it have in it
dilemma would you rather give up blow
jobs for the rest of your life
or cheese wow cheese easy cheese of
course you'd give up cheese
absolutely i'd give up cheese that
[ __ ] less dairy less stomachaches i
wouldn't get bound up less bloating wait
do i get more blow jobs did all the
cheese i don't eat does that go into
more blow jobs
because this includes the fake cheese
like cheese whiz
or mac and cheese dude i [ __ ] hate
that cheese that's that's why i could i
can never get on board with the philly
cheesesteak that have the whiz on them
uh
that's the way that's the perfect name
for it too whiz as in piss
like if cheese took a piss that's what
it is
she's whiz it's cheese
yeah it's [ __ ] gross i wonder if
that's why they call it that but maybe
dude you know what it is it's probably
some processed [ __ ] something where they
scrape it off the top of the bottom of
something yeah you know for years we
were throwing this out then we added a
little something to it all kinds of
preservatives and salt and salt we can
stay in that little aerosol can yeah
that's longer than you live on the food
chain it's below the hot dog cheese whiz
i mean cheese whiz i mean that's like
that's there with fluff another
that's in there with like i mean it's
fluffing it's actually marshmallow
spread like
it's like yummy toxic waste
it's just horrific
like that's the kind of [ __ ] you eat and
your body is just like what the [ __ ] is
this yeah where do we put this and it
just don't like that
it's trans that [ __ ] like it just sticks
it
wherever it can put it tries to spread
it out through your body yeah i'm not
into cheese whiz you'll you'll never see
it in the house it's not something that
i'm into so you don't have to worry
about that okay good
did you talk about kim and kanye's
wedding
already
what
i thought maybe you talked about kim and
kanye's wedding
why would i
i don't know why would i talk about that
they're already about topical stuff well
first they already have a [ __ ] kid
you know
stupid what do you mean what's stupid
about it
you already had a kid
what do you what so now what we're
getting married so i can be like oh my
god hey how soon before you already have
one it's dumb
it's what are you talking about i'm
saying are you saying that people say
the kids shouldn't get married if
they're not married no they should get
married if they want to but they should
make a big [ __ ] deal out of it oh but
this is kim and kanye were talking that
was such a waste of a castle they're not
[Music]
they had their they did they do it at
first sight they had their dinner like
their their like rehearsal dinner or
whatever at versailles and then they got
married in this old castle in florence
and i have to say i don't know i'm
looking at the pictures which is
hilarious because they're supposed to be
so private and we're not selling our
pictures everywhere people magazine is
like practically a guest at the whole
[ __ ] no they sell them to one and they
make a zillion bucks yeah yeah what do
you think they're going to have the
divorce at
[Laughter]
parliament in london
that's hilarious
but i'm looking at the pictures i got i
don't know i think they look they look
really happy it sounds so cheesy but
it's true i'm like i was very good i was
very skeptical of it but i have to say
they look super happy and i thought i
was going to be all eye rolling at all
the pictures can kanye smile anymore
that's the thing he's smiling in all
those pictures i mean of course it's
also for people since that car accident
when he got that that the jaw thing
going there yeah he always has like a
the the [ __ ] the [ __ ] face his resting
face is [ __ ] face like when he doesn't
move and he's just kind of sitting there
he looks angry like that he just has
that
you kind of have no way he has you kind
of had that like resting face where you
look pissed off
i definitely have that but my jaw
doesn't look like it's made out of like
he has the same jaw of like the tin man
you know like those little robots the
initial ones you make with they just
sort of he yeah but they had his jaw got
all broken so it's gonna be a little
weird oh that's right and then he wrote
a song about he went in the studio and
made a video about how awesome he was
that he was in the studio
that he had a wire that he had a
jaw wired shut
yeah oh man you gotta film this god i
can't believe how awesome i am but
that's that's when i i literally started
feeling old it's just the absolute
[ __ ]
just i mean i don't know if because
everybody started doing yoga or whatever
just these
self-blowing blowing self-blowing
blowing that just goes on like where
it's just like they they people are
amazed with how [ __ ] amazing they are
the second they get to that [ __ ]
level i i just i can't watch it it's
gross you gotta be your your your own
cheerleader though you know what i mean
you got to be your own hype man yeah it
doesn't mean you got to be an arrogant
ass
that's very true yeah
look you look you [ __ ] think negative
[ __ ] i'm getting nowhere i can't do this
then you gotta [ __ ] this i gotta do
something positive i gotta go to the gym
come on bill you can do this blah blah
blah blah that doesn't mean i gotta have
a look on my face like i just conquered
a country by myself and start yelling at
people
this is really i just feel like this is
kind of ironic coming from a man whose
job it is is to stand on stage and make
people laugh which is what i do but it's
also a part of it is like giving your
own opinions about stuff and sort of
like you know this is how i feel and of
course it's for laughs
but i mean i'm not saying what you and
kanye my point of view on stage is i'm a
[ __ ] who doesn't read who has a dd
right if you really listen to it that's
all i'm saying for an hour no one ever
thinks that about you though no they
just see an angry leprechaun
but the thing is you know you talk about
how he's hyping himself up and he says
he's so awesome like apparently at their
wedding he gave this speech and he said
like
kim is like a work of art and the
kardashians are like this amazing brand
and they're like the future he just gave
this whole like he is so
into them and her and her family in that
whole they're an amazing brand that's a
compliment that's a compliment now yeah
yeah
he did and it was saying that they're
right up there with with coaches and
yeah because of how
but the thing is though is he is he
completely wrong because they turned her
little like
z-list status sex tape into like this
million dollar industry to the point
where they're like
valentino well we're arguing with two
different things
i'm not saying they're not successful at
it so their brand is huge i'm not very
successful i'm not saying that they're
not a huge brand oh you're saying is
that a compliment if you're saying
that's a weird thing to say at a wedding
but when you're complimenting a family
you're an amazing brand
i can see you guys whoring out all the
other aspects of your private lives
to to well listen he he himself has said
he's not the greatest speaker you know
what i mean like the way it comes out
doesn't always come out the right way i
don't but for a family who's trying to
be a brand you know that is a huge
compliment can i tell you something
just god damn it and i'm not trying to
be a dick here oh god what what do they
do what exactly do they do everybody
always asks that question well it's a
valid what do they do they have a tv
show they have various fashion lines and
cosmetics and the whole like sort of
like i know what they have they have
retail stores i know what they have what
they do what are they doing
they are the faces of their businesses
so they are reality stars they are
reality personalities
who have then transcended the reality
genre into legitimate
million dollar businesses including
clothing and et cetera
and they you know that's in their
spokespeople for various brands all
those pictures of them come out of
around in paris that they came out of
haagen-dazs is paying them for that i
know so so they get money just to hold
an ice cream cone
which i'll take any [ __ ] day of the
week
so seriously so let me ask you guys
let me
know
hundred thousand dollars you and your
wife come out of haagen-dazs holding ice
cream no
no you wouldn't do it though no
because then because then i then you
become them then then everything you say
i i've i'm i'm still of that
i'm still of that
that old school thing where
look
this this is this is i've come to this
point as far as what i think selling out
is selling out is not something that the
fans decide so i shouldn't i'm not even
a fan of this but as an observer of them
i shouldn't say whether they sold out or
not
it's yeah i really think it comes down
to the performer
and basically selling out is when you
don't want to do something but you do it
anyways because of the money and then
afterwards you feel [ __ ] horrible
to me
if that's what you feel like at the end
of it
then then you you sold yourself out you
did i don't think selling out doesn't
eat i feel like selling out isn't even a
real thing anymore i just feel like
that's how [ __ ]
concept is that i feel like there's no
the idea of selling out there
i don't i don't feel that it really
truly exists anymore oh okay there's
okay platforms for artists to make money
and you know your time can come and go
very quickly so if you can get a hundred
thousand dollars for holding an ice
cream cone and getting your picture
taken is that really gonna like keep you
up at night like i can't believe i did
that for the money
you know no i'm not saying it's going to
i'm not saying it's not going to i'm
going to say with some people it is
and some people it isn't
yeah but you're you're very you're but
you are you're very particular about
where you choose to
do any kind of advertising and stuff
because you care about stuff like that
so i understand look i i mean i i do
like advertising
on this podcast i'm not against it i'm
not saying
that
i mean love jesus christ i mean that's
how this whole [ __ ] business i mean i
gotta advertise for my shows and that
type of thing but it's it's it's like
anything it's like hey i like to drink
then there's a point where you've drank
too much and you're making an ass to
yourself there's there there are limits
to everything i'm not i'm not gonna sit
here and be like oh this is like i'm
doing this grassroots thing i'm not
saying that
but what i'm saying is
like just that that whole selling out
thing i i think it still exists but it's
it's up to the individual so
i would never say that somebody if i see
somebody do a commercial they sold out
it'd have to come from them
it'd have to come from them where if
they did it and then afterwards they're
like oh my god i was in all these great
movies and next thing you know i'm
standing there doing a cell phone
[ __ ] commercial and when i saw it
i just felt like what did i do what did
i do to my image because this whole
[ __ ] game
you know is is constantly trying to stay
ahead so they don't [ __ ] pigeonhole
you and then also not stepping on a
[ __ ] landmine
which is doing a bad movie or putting
out a badge special there's all these
different landmines that you're trying
not to step on
but uh
i i definitely i think that there's
there's always there's definitely ways
that you you can sell out but like the
the younger me would you you know i
bonded that whole bill hicks thing of
like you know you do do a commercial
you're off the artistic roll call and i
and i was hardcore
believing that and then
like you know just getting older and
it's just like now look it's it it all
comes down like it's your career
you do
what you want look there's people out
there levine does commercials for a
proactive but so do a lot it's like
diddy did one katy perry does one a lot
of them do that whole i had acne and it
made me feel really bad about myself and
now i am proactive and now i'm happy
again yeah and this is the thing they
can all afford proactive so you're
basically just going there to get paid
right and you're going to stand there
and hold it more closer up to your face
now to me that would make me want to go
jump off a [ __ ] building
okay i felt weird when i first started
doing advertising on this thing but what
i what i tried to do was like oh at
least i'll try to make these things
[ __ ] funny but i'm not against
taking like you know um
advertising money i guess if you really
believe in it like the [ __ ] that i've
i've read on this stuff the stuff that i
believe in
right
i [ __ ] read it and then if it sounds
[ __ ] stupid to me well you know i
just like this one i do i just say it
sounds to what am i going i'm just
saying
it wasn't you know look it was beyond
sherry's barriers in nature's box
there's some [ __ ] that [ __ ] didn't
even make the podcast there was there
was one thing that i read when i wasn't
even thinking one week it was some some
[ __ ] banker thing and my buddy you
know andrew who you know puts the whole
all the list together and everything
that i read he was in banking he said
bill these guys they're tricking people
they're doing this and they're gonna
[ __ ] over your listeners so i
immediately took it off and i was they
were supposed to do a three week thing
and i had read one of them and i just
told my ad lady said listen just take
them off that first one's a free one up
they don't have to pay me but i don't
want to read
i don't want to read because you know i
don't i don't have time to [ __ ] look
at all of those things so sometimes i
will read something
that i don't believe in
and then
if i'm smart enough when i catch it as
i'm reading it i make fun of it that's
what i do i make fun of it and say it's
[ __ ] and then they get mad
right and they yell at me
or yell at my ad lady and then we just
go alright well we're not gonna [ __ ]
you're not gonna be on the podcast then
it's cool right which is funny so like
you can't get fired off your own podcast
so
um
look i'm not saying that like
you know i don't want people thinking
that i'm sitting there saying that i'm
this righteous [ __ ] person i'm not
saying that but there's definitely
you know
there's i i i there's always there's
always selling out
there's all and unless you just
completely don't give a [ __ ]
you never gave a [ __ ] just like look
if you're gonna pay me i'm gonna [ __ ]
do it then then i but less about selling
out and more about like survival and
more about like you know let me just
sort of hit everything oh if you need
the [ __ ] money if you need look if
you're sitting there in a house and
they're going to throw you out and then
kitkat comes up says hey we want you to
wear a thong and go down a water slide
backwards i mean you got to sit there
and be like
ah [ __ ] man i got to do it i mean i
can't be on the [ __ ] street maybe
it's not their first choice to you know
be paid by haagen-dazs to get married
but he's also they're also having a you
know a wedding and or whatever in
versailles and that's just got to be
paid for but listen so haagen-dazs paid
for that look i'm not saying i'm not
saying
that
that if you do that you sold out but i'm
not saying that if you do it you didn't
it all depends on on the person after
they did it after they [ __ ] did it
how did they feel if they thought [ __ ]
that was great that was easy money blah
blah and they continue on
then i don't think they sold themselves
out i really at this point in my life i
feel like selling out is is is a
personal thing and as much as fans will
accuse of you of a person of it or
whatever
um
that it's just speculation because it
really comes down to the person like
like a lot of musicians now i mean
because the whole star making thing went
away
there is no mtv there is no videos there
is there there aren't these labels
in these cd stores now it really is on
your own it you know back in the day
when i was growing up if if your
music was in a car and it was in any
commercial
you were a [ __ ] sellout
and like that really like people just
said he's a [ __ ] sellout he took the
corporate buck and all it was a really
thing because
there was all these other ways i think
then
where you could you could still be this
big person but now be like this pure
artist uncorrupted by the system that
you're trying to get into and that's
kind of the whole [ __ ] point of it
nah nah see now that i disagree with it
i just i just i disagree with that
because what you're saying is either
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] sucking dick
or you're this lonely bastard rather
than
then you can be in a healthy [ __ ]
relationship there's plenty of people
that look there's plenty of people that
that are in this business and they they
just do their movies so they just do
that tv show there's a zillion people
and you don't see them going like i'll
tell you when i come home from work and
i want to relax i [ __ ] blah blah blah
blah there's plenty of people that don't
do that now i'm not saying that they're
any better than the people who decide
like yeah [ __ ] it i'll take the money to
go to a product actually like that
product or whatever i'm i'm really
saying it's it's an individual
it's an individual thing all right how
you want to be perceived
you know how you want to go about this
business and i think the more the people
do it the less
um
the uh the less it's going to have like
that stigma like i mean you see a lot of
these movie stars that are doing it the
commercials now it's because people
stole movies so right now basically the
only movies that they make it's this
shrinking puddle the only movies that
they make now are either those hundred
zillion dollar transformer godzilla
things where even though they're gonna
be on a pirate bay
um people still will hopefully want to
get the experience or it's going to be a
low budget thing the thing that got
killed was the 30 50 60 80 million
dollar movie those things are gone
not totally if you get like a martin
scorsese behind it you can get the thing
made but like
like
i don't have the exact numbers i was
talking to my agent about this
because i'm seeing a lot i'm seeing a
lot of movie stars all of a sudden going
back to doing stand-up i'm seeing a lot
of them doing like like uh
commercials and all that type of thing
it isn't necessarily because they want
to it's because the business has changed
and is going in the direction
of the uh
of of the music business then so then
yeah so then i
to that end and they i don't think they
can be accused of selling out either you
know because of everything that you said
i don't think you can you can you can
accuse anybody of selling out but the
only person who knows i feel
is the person who did it if afterwards
when you [ __ ] you walked out of there
if you felt like you needed a shower
if you just you know you're sitting
there and drag
[ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] you're doing
whatever job it is that you're doing
um
and believe me i i've had those i don't
feel like it affects people's brands or
images
in that way anymore like i just don't
know i don't either i don't either
people thought like kanye even getting
involved with kim kardashian let alone
marrying her and singing of the praises
of her and her family was gonna like
destroy his fan base and no
no way it's not happening if anything
it's gonna make it even bigger here's
one for you this is how much this
business has changed with the perception
back in the day if you were a movie star
you're a movie star and you did not do
tv that was considered a major [ __ ] up i
mean you could start the business doing
your commercials and then once you got
to the tv level or something it was
really hard when you were a tv star like
they weren't even oh though people see
you on tv you are this
you are that
you know you're a commercial actor
you're a movie star you're a tv star and
then you know over the years it started
to like you know i mean it was it was
still it was an amazing thing back in
the day when a guy like bruce willis
went from moonlighting
and then he did die hard and all of a
sudden he was this [ __ ] movie star i
mean that was that was like that was
still an amazing thing to do and now
it's like people jump back and forth
which i think
is um is a cool thing but way back in
the day it's smart who's
who is that um
that that actor and that actress we went
um we went to that party and turned out
she had lived uh around the corner uh
african-american actress from like the
30s or 40s dated that [ __ ] dorothy
dandridge yeah
now she dated this guy or married this
this white dude who had a [ __ ] supper
club yeah
and
he marries her and is convincing her
that she should go down there as a movie
star and sing at his supper club in
hollywood that is not going to be filmed
nobody's going to see it and all of her
friends begged her don't do that that's
going to kill your [ __ ] movie career
if you as a movie star are seen singing
in this supper club and out of love for
this guy who turned out to be not a good
guy she did it and it actually hurt her
movie career so back then
you know like like how hard core those
lines were back then i don't think that
that exists anymore but i i have to tell
you though there are certain people that
i don't want to see doing a [ __ ]
snickers commercial or yes i know yeah
how did you feel when you saw joe pesci
in the snickers commercial
i didn't mind
but those things are well written in the
way it is is what they're actually
saying is
you're not yourself right so there's
almost this way that they it's it's a
really slick way to get the celebrity in
and out where they they don't they can
just sort of not have to take a full
shower just sort of dab their forehead
take their bag of money and and leave
look i'm not saying i i would never do
one of those but as of right now
like i just feel like uh
i don't know i i like telling my jokes
and i like doing the acting gigs that
they give me and i think that at the end
of it all
you want to have uh quality
you want to have quality and i don't and
i just always i always feel like when
something that comes down the pike
that is just a money [ __ ] gig
there's always that okay i could take
this or i could just do a couple extra
weekends of stand up and i could make up
you know
some of that money and yeah and then i
don't have that
but i mean we all got our [ __ ]
[ __ ] when we were coming up everybody's
got some
student films and [ __ ] that you mean
like that stuff i don't count but i
really feel that uh
you know um i i but i at the end of it i
thought i i just i just feel it's a
personal thing
they're like look there's people who
they get sick of doing the road it's
like i don't want to [ __ ] go out
there anymore i don't want to [ __ ]
deal with the check
spots i don't want to deal with the
drunks after i just i just i don't want
to get on another [ __ ] airplane
okay i've had it the old me wanted to do
that i did that and i proved that i
could do that if you want me to go do a
[ __ ] commercial
and take this [ __ ] money and i'm a
day and a half and it pays my mortgage
for the year i'll do it and i don't
think there's a [ __ ] thing wrong with
that there you go okay i don't think
there's anything wrong with it there you
go unless
unless afterwards you feel like a filthy
[ __ ] [ __ ]
so well for me like i yeah and i
completely understand i think for me i
think i had to sort of come to terms
with the fact that like i am just like a
pop culture like i want to see all that
stuff so in a way
i'm glad that like they're all out there
and their pictures are being sold to
people magazine because i want to
[ __ ] see the wedding i want to see
like who wins and what they're wearing
and what the castle looked like and all
that kind of stuff and this is how i
feel about that show this i feel about
that show i find that show depressing
i find it unbelievable
kardashians i find it depressing when
they're dealing with depressing [ __ ]
otherwise it's like kind of mindless
mindless entertainment
i find i find the whole [ __ ] thing
the stuff with lamar i find that whole
[ __ ] thing walking around
in in your expensive shoes and your
flashy bag and this whole perception
of this life that you're leading i i
find all of that
i don't know why i look at it i find it
gross and i just find it depressing i'm
not saying that somebody shouldn't live
that life and if that's what makes them
happy it makes them happy any time i've
ever gone to those [ __ ] businesses
it's all like it's
aspirational it's just like it's like a
fa it's a fantasy thing like everyone
wants to sort of
live in a world where they're in a movie
or in their magazine like you know what
i mean like it's just part of like
i'll tell you i'll tell you this as far
as like cars i [ __ ]
love cars okay
but i think it's so much more cooler
what they do on those shows where they
take an old car
you know like fast and loud and what
they do because there's an artistry to
that
the stuff that they do for everything
from the deciding if this car can we
bring this thing back to life
and then just seeing the old technology
and then seeing what aaron does to
upgrade it and then the whole art of
richard trying to flip the whole thing i
mean that to me is way more compelling
than just going down to the lot being
i'm super successful
uh so so-and-so has one of those let me
get that and let me get that in [ __ ]
this color and let me get the [ __ ]
lambos [ __ ] suicide doors and then
i'm gonna call the paparazzi
and i'm gonna go to where the [ __ ]
they're at and i'm gonna have decked out
head to toe and the sunglass people paid
me to wear it and i'm gonna step out
and then act like oh why are you here
that [ __ ] to me is is i find that gross
yeah it's up there definitely an element
of buttons to it there's an arc to
everything so i'm sure that there is an
art to doing that and the fact that like
people are what like they are they have
become successful just by showing
themselves on tv at not as you said not
doing anything quote unquote not being
actors or singers or anything like that
just being themselves and they have
built this like sort of empire
off of originally
a notorious thing that happened
it's i don't know is that not impressive
are you not entertained
um no no no i'm not saying what they did
was bad or anything i just personally
when i watch it i just think it's gross
i think it's gross that somebody's
daughter
and she made that [ __ ] video
and if what they said was true that her
mother like i don't know if it leaked
out and then her mother did like the
most amazing spin job ever that's i
think that's
to me that's what happened this thing
well i i think that that's the story
they tell because a lot of people how do
you know she wasn't like kim get on your
knees and suck that dick
we have to get out of this part of town
hilton had a sex tape and it didn't she
didn't sort of go off to become this
thing that you know her what are you
talking about
that's irrelevant
she was the original
i'm i'm bringing nothing to the table
i'm just showing up to these events
right
she was the original yeah of course so
what happens is just like
you know somebody sets the the bar for
guitar playing somebody comes along and
has to has to outdo that she set the bar
for empty-headed
skinny [ __ ] going to a club who's got
more money than she [ __ ] needs so
then kim comes along it's like well i
gotta out do that
so then metaphorically sucking the dick
i will literally suck it
and
and and god help
but that she was already famous when she
did it yeah that's the difference she
was already famous for doing nothing
where kim
wasn't famous for doing nothing and then
became famous for doing nothing wait i
wanted to ask you about one other thing
really quickly well i have i have
advertising to read oh you do
yeah speaking of words let's go into
your lovely advertising i want to talk
to you about bruce willis and demi
moore's this is almost a [ __ ]
two-hour podcast i gotta get out of here
too long
well depends on how long somebody's ride
is to work
um
you know what i wanna hear from you guys
i wanna hear from the fads those are
called 1800 no calm let me know uh where
the [ __ ] did the ads go did i finish
them all
um oh here it is yeah
i wanna know what you got what do you
guys think is selling out
you know what do you think that selling
out exists anymore like i i don't feel
like it really is a thing anymore well i
think also if you grow up
just seeing movie stars doing
commercials i don't think it's like a
big deal let's think about them too i
mean
you know these last five years has
really changed because it was funny when
you were in this country you didn't see
movie stars on billboards and [ __ ] like
that and then you went to australia you
go to europe you see like leonardo doing
the tag heuer [ __ ] things and all
this [ __ ]
um
and way back in the day oh my god
bradley cooper doing ads for haagen-dazs
actually his pictures there he might not
be coming out of the thing like kanye
and kim he might actually be coming out
of the store i have to be honest with
you when i think about that when i think
about that it's like what's the how much
[ __ ] money
do you gotta make you you're [ __ ] the
star of those those the the three
hangover movies you got money for life
yeah but
why not make the life but why not do
that and add to the income because i
look at it but going
eventually like you said i want to keep
doing movies and acting oh i get that
listen listen i always say when this
business is finished with me they
probably have that same this this i know
this is my deal i look at it like okay
so you do all those movies and you're
not getting any more movies then you
[ __ ] do them
[ __ ] it i'll do a commercial then you do
it but when you're [ __ ] up there
i mean the guy was just and then he was
in another movie that was up for like
best picture and people want to oscar
you gotta but the thing is you'll make
more money doing it while you're the big
star so it doesn't make any sense to do
it after you fall off because then
they're like yeah here's five grand take
it or leave it and you're like [ __ ] i
gotta take it no take it now bank it
uh i don't know about that i feel like
that's a that's a smarter business
decision not to wait until you're like
nobody wants you anymore and then you'll
hold an ice cream cone like hi
but then no one even [ __ ] cares
that's the other thing i wanna i wanna
you know what i would love to talk to a
movie star tell and ask them how they
feel
about about sitting there with the ice
and then
looking at the spoon
you know what's funny though
i just look at it as another acting gig
i think i think kim came out with the
ice cream kanye was just in there but he
wasn't holding he wasn't photographed
holding anything and then like her mom
has a picture holy and her sister has
one so i think kanye was like all right
yeah i'll go in there with you but i'm
not [ __ ] coming out there with the
ice cream cone can i ask you questions i
love you can i ask you a question
does any of that
make you want to buy haagen-dazs ice
cream like it's not like i'm sitting on
the fence going you know i don't know
about that haagen-dazs i love bradley
cooper
what flavor is he eating
jesus get me three pints of it i think
it's supposed to be more subliminal than
that
all right let's let's just [ __ ] read
this so we can get out of here uh
e-voice everybody now it's my turn to
[ __ ] myself out um this is this is my
haagen-dazs ice cream right here perfect
uh
um if you take all your business calls
yourself it's hard to look professional
or get anything done by helping you
expertly manage all your business calls
evoice provides you with a better
way to connect your to your clients with
a toll-free number professional voice
greeting and a dial by name directory
e-voice transforms any phone into your
business phone nia please don't be
texting when i'm doing this my
peripheral i can't i already can't read
when there's nothing going on uh when
your customers call they are
automatically sent to you to wherever
you are your calls are uh you could be
at home you could be at the office or
sitting in your favorite ballpark having
a beer you're always going to sound like
a fortune 500 company yeah unless the
drunks are streaming screaming around
you right
um whatever there's always a fly in the
ointment anyways and you can get all
this for only 13 for under 13 bucks a
month for a limited time my listeners
can try evois for free for 60 days
that's right 60 days but this extended
trial will not last forever you have to
do it now go to evoice.com and enter the
promo code bill upon checkout to get
your special offer make sure you hurry
because this offer will end soon go to
evoice.com promo code bill bill that's
evoice dot com promo code bill and
lastly but not least lee
legal zoom everybody
america was built
by inventors and dreamers
and murderous maniacs that thought their
race was better than the others people
like thomas edison and henry ford laid
the foundation for our country
um these days it's the inventors and
entrepreneurs all around us like you
that keep our country running by fueling
the job market in the economy this month
legalzoom celebrates innovations by
helping you launch your dream apply for
a patent to secure your invention i love
this thing
all right people people who invented
stuff always get taken advantage of all
right patent your thing that whatever
you're inventing and when you go to
those corporate you know what's
um do not give up ownership now you're
probably going to have to or they'll
just steal it from you
anyways register your trademark to
promote uh protect your products and
services incorporate or form an llc and
launch your business
best thing you do i guess is settle out
of court with them right visit
legalzoom.com and use the discount code
burr burr they'll provide the
professional attention you need and help
take care of all the details they've
helped over a million businesses get
started right and they received an
a-plus from the better business bureau
bureau celebrate innovations with
legalzoom today and a special offer
price or trademark copyright or
provisional patent application by using
the discount code burr at checkout
legalzoom provides legal help through
independent attorneys and self-help but
they are not a law firm legalzoom.com
discount code burr hey nia
yeah yeah yeah come in here for you know
what's funny about this i was just
thinking as i was reading that
was that
later on in my career right
when it's all [ __ ] said and done and
they are done with me and i'm doing a
zagnut bar commercial
people will take the audio from this
absolutely yeah but i never said that it
was i never i said it was an individual
thing i i will tell you this and i can
tell you without a [ __ ] doubt
as far as i feel that if i ever did one
of those
that i i would i don't know how i would
be able i mean i guess you change every
four or five years
you know i guess as you become an older
man and you just don't want to [ __ ]
go out there i like how you change your
physicality when you say yeah older man
you're such an actor at heart you just
kind of like bent over made yourself
physically an old man becoming an older
man yeah you just you're like you know
what you win
i eat candy bars i like this candy bar i
don't give a [ __ ]
if you want to pay for my prostate exam
this month go ahead do it now the fear
is that yeah the business will be done
with you and you're not going to have
anywhere to turn so yeah but i i have to
know but i make your money and hopefully
you can oh but there's other plans you
can do
no you pay your [ __ ] house you buy a
house you can afford and you pay the
[ __ ] thing off and then the next
thing you do is you go out you buy
rental properties and then you don't
[ __ ] those people over but they help pay
that thing off and then in the end of
your life if you got a problem you can
sell one of those [ __ ] units that's
what i want to do as opposed
to going on and sitting there look with
an amazed look on my face as the micro
microwave popcorn is popping
okay
this but this is the thing actually i
shouldn't even say that because there's
so many commercials that i think are so
funny
and great and i think the performances
commercials are like oh they're way
better than level now yeah they're way
better than they used to be but i guess
the nightmare is
you know what it is you just don't want
to be in something that sucks yeah
that's [ __ ] cheesy maybe maybe that's
what it is but that's a chance you take
with every movie or tv show you do you
don't really know as an actor unless you
are like the director or a producer not
just a name but a real producer on it
you have no idea how it's going to go so
you will go but you get the script it's
going to be awesome yeah you think this
is going to be so funny script is a
great director writer boom and it comes
out and it's true but you're telling me
that that same do you think that's do
you think that same thing happens when
you get the copy for the zagnut bar
commercial no but at least you know we
should tell you on paper this looks good
no but you know you know exactly what
you're getting into you know exactly the
purpose for this thing no you don't you
don't know exactly what you're getting
what you're selling is that i can't
believe it's a zagnut you're so oh
you're so old sometimes
snickers
fifth avenue fifth evan
because you have no power on how they're
going to edit it you don't know who's
[ __ ] directing the goddamn thing you
don't know how if they if the editor is
good commercial
as opposed to wow this is really
something that i was really believed in
it's unfortunate that it didn't you know
you didn't get to see what we really did
speaking of that how many but how many
people's careers were ruined by one that
one batman movie
which one well the one with the chicken
wings
meow
and when the girl went oh yeah oh no she
played poison oh check from scarface
michelle pfeiffer and then the guy the
guy doing the [ __ ] the guy doing the
tv show with ll cool j
chris chris uh chris christensen
he played robin o'donnell he played
robin his career wasn't ruined he's on
that cs no it was whatever he took a
major [ __ ] hit he didn't write that
goddamn movie
yeah but he he was on the [ __ ] ropes
because of that movie
yeah well you know
what what no i don't know what
i'm not trying to do a two-hour podcast
is like seeing a 200 point nba
later on so we can talk about
uh what is that word mean
addendum that's like an additional scout
willis what
we can do it's been over two hours i
don't think my listeners give a [ __ ]
about what what happened with scout
willis
well she's uh she was went parading
around new york uh topless because she
was
in protest of instagram
cutting out her account because you know
she was wearing a sheer top and his
shoulder nipples and that's been a thing
where people's nipples or whatever have
been on instagram like they shut down
rihanna's account
because she posted some pictures from a
magazine she like a french magazine
shoot she did and then this editor at
vogue
uh named grace coddington just put a
picture like a stick figure thing with
little nipples on it and they shut down
her account they gave her account back
because it was ridiculous because of the
cartoon but this whole thing now where
instagram is like
you know cutting people out for
excessive nudity and [ __ ] so scout
willis in protest quote-unquote when
walking around topless
in new york city and had her picture
taken and stuff because she was like i
just got my breasts reduced i feel good
about myself and you know instagram is
shaming people and i think it's the most
ridiculous
non-cause
ever like really scout willis the
daughter of the like famous movie stars
you're really being oppressed by
instagram because they want to shut down
the [ __ ] nipples it was the most
insane ridiculous thing i had ever seen
what do you think about their uh
yeah i mean i don't i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah no nudity sure fine i feel like i
still see plugins
just booty shots on it yeah that's like
youtube it's like you know there's a
certain level of whoredom that you can
go to and then they stop because they're
trying to protect their image yeah we're
not trying to become a porno hub exactly
and they've got all kinds of young kids
on it so they're trying to be mindful of
that too they don't want it to be you
know what's funny about views are like
don't use instagram you can show your
tits in a zillion places on the [ __ ]
internet that's just like you know i
talk i wouldn't talk like this in church
i might let on an old easy during
somebody's speech but you know right you
got to respect it's instagram that's
that's their church well at the end yeah
and that's what the girls away i know i
don't the thing is though she's really
trying to make it about censorship and
you're shaming women and like men can go
around it's like
you are not shamed or being like
oppressed in any way daughter of famous
yeah guys are being oppressed okay guys
are being oppressed
because you get to look at man tits all
the time
and i can't see you know that's all
that's all we're thinking about is man
tits male 1 male packs male pecks i'm
sure you're and i'm sure you're really
like scared about pets about all the
people googling your your pecs right you
live sort of in that fear of oh i hate
going to the beach i i look like a piece
of chalk that was uh somebody threw some
cinnamon at
flex some cinnamon all i know is that it
really
annoyed me
that scout willis had the nerve
to act like she was somehow being
oppressed in any way because instagram
banned her account what do you expect
from somebody named scout
what do you think they're going to
[ __ ] do their parents were movie
stars what do you think they're going to
do you know even rihanna is like
whatever moving on and just has her
twitter account now and she and the
thing is she wasn't even doing it like
i'm doing it for rihanna in fact she's
explicit i'm not gonna try to act like
all black people know each other but is
there any way you can get in touch with
her and tell her to stop drawing on
herself
her tattoos oh my god yes no i don't i
don't know rihanna so no i wouldn't with
her with her uh with her air force
tattoo that under her tits oh it's like
an egyptian
something that's not an iron maiden uh
power slave album cover no no then she
has that little love she wants with her
body what's your she has that little sam
on the side what's what's your problem
with rihanna having a bunch of tattoos
she's got a beautiful body she has a
great canvas for it yeah i know and so
you start scribbling all over it
oh but you're like anti you're not
completely anti-tattoo but you're kind
of our anti-tattoo no you know what i
don't like i don't like when somebody
tries to write something [ __ ] deep
on on their rib cage or their shoulder
blade
like hey
the next time the butterfly flaps its
wings
you're talking about megan fox just no
i'm not oh because she got something
about butterflies we'll laugh oh she did
gilded butterfly or something oh jesus
when the fire dances with the water on
the butterfly
wings with that drunk jim morrison
horseshit you got on the back of your
[ __ ] leg i don't give a [ __ ] like
like like just advertising that you you
understand life or some [ __ ] like i'm
supposed to be like wow that person is
deep
yeah do you know tattoo artists don't
like doing those things
yeah because they feel like they say
they feel like they're on punishment
like they're writing like i will not
talk in class because they're just
sitting there writing there's nothing
creative about it yeah well then that's
we'll see that's how i feel about scout
willis it was i was very my role my eyes
rolled in the back of my head i was
having a seizure that's how all right we
were at the two-hour mark we are at the
two-hour mark i'm gonna end this [ __ ]
fest thanks for having me on the podcast
on my birthday yeah no worries it's
already 3 15 though
half over
no it isn't was half over at noon
you